ladies and gentlemen good afternoon and
welcome strap for District Council for
our December council meeting I'll now
ask my chaplain the key to open
proceedings with our with a prayer
there's a judgment if and when you're
asked to speak can I ask you to speak
directly into the microphone from a
short distance away otherwise will not
will not be picked up on any recording
that we make thank you I call on
executive director to report list of
reporters Thank You chairman
we have apologists and counsel of Romick
canceler Giles councillor Kendall
councillor Lawton and councillor
Williams thank you
I've known bright members and officers
to make their declarations of interest
in the meeting David chairman myself and
Isabel have an interest in relation to
item number 15 and we live in the
meeting for that item thank you thank
you very much
moving on to point three you've all had
a copy of the minutes I now seek a
proposer and a seconder for the minutes
of the meeting held on the fifteenth of
October 2018 chair [ __ ] ass I got a
question on the minutes on page 13 it
says councillor Jefferson advised that
he would send a full response to Council
aboard you on this matter but I've not
had a response I presumed people have
read the minutes oh I'm surprised that
hasn't been flagged earlier but close
understand when then getting that
response my apologies councillor Ward we
all get you one before the end of the
week
thank you I was going to say a week this
is purely to record the accuracy the
minutes not the contents thereof mr.
Vaudrey but the leader has leptin and
cover the matter so thank you do we have
any concerns or comments on the accuracy
of your minutes if not can I propose a
and seconder please close the pari that
council
happy to propose proposing second
accounts the bills are we agreed
thank you I know gone to Chairman's and
dunst months this has been a a busy time
I've had the honor of meeting the earl
of wessex and more and moral in his role
as trustee of Jughead and reward scheme
as brightest traps pont-aven see scouts
at their base in stratford I attended
the Lord Mayor of Coventry as charity
dinner judge the best entry at the
Victorian market at a guided tour of
Royal Mail stratford sorting office been
to a number of musical productions in
stratford and warwick and a production
of the RSC of trials Cressida I tend to
Series events commemorating the
hundredth anniversary of the end of
World War one starting with a remarkable
production of the Bearpit theater of the
last episode of Black Adder not a comedy
Paul's to not bullets punches but the
emotions of those having to go over the
top I'd like to thank all those who took
part in who attended in our own
commemorations on the 8th of November in
particular the reading of her own poem
by Annabel Pete the readings by Nicholas
Jones have cares and Archie halter
bishops which into primary school and
the playing of the last poster Ravalli
by bugler Lawrence may again of cares
supported by our QMS Huntington from DM
Kyneton and officiated by the reverent
Neville Bhima I think is here today the
purpose of our commemoration was to
launch the district's new newly created
role of honour and I'd like to thank
Tony perks and Craig ball on his council
and Wendy Buckley from Bishop search
engine and parish Clark's across the
district for their work on this project
putting this role of honor together for
those who weren't there on the day
fifteen hundred and sixty-seven
residents this district did not come
home just on a 300 from this town 464
mile market towns and over 800 from the
84 settlements in the district for the
total male population of 27,000 those
that died were approximately one-sixth
of those aged between
20 and 40 one-sixth of a whole
generation did not come home I also
attended remembrance ceremonies a
witness LEM Eaton and of course here in
Stratford three days later and with a
round trip of some fifty our 52 hours of
traveling and attending the opening
ceremony of the 2018 China International
friendship Studies conference in Wuhan a
city in central China on the Yangtze
River it's about there on the map the
opening address was given by the vice
president of China mr. Wang Qishan
followed by the former Prime Minister of
Japan Yukio Hatoyama and the Vice
President of Uganda adversus candy some
eight hundred delegates attended the
conference with representatives from 60
countries from around the world and 115
cities from within China the first day
comprised a series of short speeches
from delegates on a variety of topics
including the benefits of cooperation
urban transformation ecology and
enhancing of and competitiveness on the
second day travel district council along
with 101 other cities from around within
China and the rest of the world receipt
friendship city awards as being for our
own contribution to working with the
city of fugu a theme which no doubt you
will all be familiar more importantly of
the hundred and two Prize winners for
were selected to address the conference
after the awards were given on the topic
of experience sharing Stratford
being one of those chosen the four of us
had the unlimited opportunity to address
the conference about our relationships
with our partner cities and how working
together can bring benefits to both
parties I spoke to the conference about
the very successful relationship we have
been building with the city of Fujio
the exciting developments of the three
dramatist Park at San Wang and how
Stratford
as well the West Midlands leading
economic areas supported by well-known
international brands along with the
planned 40 million expansion of
on campus warrant University and of
course as a world leading cultural
destination could benefit from
infrastructure improvements the mayor of
Fujio was grateful for the coverage I
gave his city a road through the small
one with only three million people but
afterwards I was approached by a number
of other leading Chinese cities came to
offer to build new links in the UK and
with Stratford in particular and in view
of and keen to support our own cultural
offering I'd like to think that
Stratford's Chinese and international
profile has been raised by our
attendance at this conference as it has
in the past when we've attended previous
events with council Saints and others
who have been there since 2016 I would
like to thank all those who helped me
get me there and back in one piece
named Eclair and Tina and Dave David and
Tony Jason for their efforts to support
me easily surpassing that provided by
our own foreign and colonial office
diplomats in China and the local support
I received from mr. Wang Jian mr. Fuji
from Peru and mr. yang T dong from Hunan
representing the the Midlands engine
based in Natyam sure with whom we hope
to work as more in the future during the
conference in addition to our contacts
in Fujian I was approached among others
by the director of JAXA Foreign Affairs
Office this child Hugh who's in the
center of the picture in front of you
the vice president the junction Chamber
of Commerce in Hebei mr. Wang Ling J on
the Left the Secretary General Jackson
provincial Association for friendship
mr. Walton mrs. Hawaiian mailing and the
director of the Foreign Affairs Division
Department of foreign and overseas
offices in affairs in Chengdu mr. yang
shimmy all of whom want to develop their
relation with us and to see us in
Stratford China is investing all over
the world and thanks to our magnate
William Shakespeare there are great
opportunities for Stratford from China
we do not will not however the only
cultural center looking to enhance their
worldwide profile the Chinese sport and
I believe we need to build on this
opportunity that we have already
rated for Stratford before our cultural
competitors jump on this bandwagon we've
got a great opportunity we must make the
most of it the age of gentlemen that
concludes my announcements
I'd now like to make the following
announcement firstly mr. Ian green all
who I know sitting in front of us who
has completed 40 years service to the
council and I would like to ask and come
forward he's probably seen this
I have to say in skill in producing
last-minute brochures pictures
slideshows for me on my trips to China
has been hugely welcome I now invite the
leader of the council followed by the
executive director to give their
announcements Thank You chair just a few
items from me we had a meeting with the
University of Warwick regarding the
development of wealth on campus that was
very much an initial meeting I've had a
meeting with jeremy wright MP about
various issues we've had a visit by andy
street to venture house all cabinet were
present at that meeting
i've also had a a telephone discussion
with Grant Shapps MP chair of the All
Party Parliamentary Group on aviation
unsurprisingly that was about Wellsville
an airfield we've also had the first
joint Warwick District Council Stratford
district council executive and cabinet
meeting and that is going to be the
first of what we hope will be a series
of meetings and this morning there was a
meeting with the police and crime
Commissioner and the Chief Constable
regarding the police precept and I
believe that consultation will be done
on three levels of increase an increase
of 12 pounds for band D 18 pounds and 24
pounds Thank You chair mr. Webb
Thank You chairman I've got no
announcements at this point thank you
we try again mr. Webb
no right we move on and this is a moment
of sadness we have lost to former
chairman of the council councillor
Stewart leaves and Eric pain and I'm
grateful that Julie and Maggie are both
with are here with us today as I had not
met Stuart I have asked his fellow
counsel into organ to say a few words
about Stuart on my behalf and I know
councillor Mort also has a few words to
remember our former colleague clearly
after Linda and Peter spoken if any
other councillors would like to share
their memories of Stuart Plue please
feel free to do so and I should just say
at this point I wanted to address
Brooks sad loss first and will clearly
be moving onto Eric's next though if we
do it's June at this moment Linda Thank
You chairman Stewart he was a dedicated
and hardworking councillor
he served this council with distinction
both as a proactive ward member and an
inspired chairman and he is remembered
by the district council here he's up
there not only was he committed to
serving his residents in the council
both the town and the district he also
had a great sense of humor and expressed
irony to perfection
he was a good friend he was very
hospitable we spent many hours together
and with others at Craig cleave working
on council business and chewing the curd
he had a unique ability to mix people
together to get results and working with
him was a great pleasure he will be
sadly missed by his family by his many
friends and by the Town of Stratford
thank you
Thank You chairman chairman as you
mentioned where they contributed a to
two former councillors and obviously
we'll come back to Eric in a moment but
it did strike me how similar they both
were in one particular way that they
both always appear to be cheerful nearly
all the time and to keep their good
humor no matter what happened and that's
not necessarily a feature that all of us
share all of the time in chairmen that
approach certainly applied to Stuart he
was always willing to sit down and
discuss the merits or otherwise of a
proposal he was putting forward and to
do so in a way that left you feeling
good at the end of the discussion like
many of us he wasn't originally from
Stratford but he made the town his home
he was heavily involved in planning in
shaping the future of the time in his
time on this council and although he
disagreed on some aspects of this I
never doubted that Stuart had the best
interests of the town at heart it's ten
years now since he was chairman of this
council but I think he would still
recognize much of what still goes on and
probably be amused that many of the
issues were still discussing were being
discussed in his day as well so as I
said Jim he was heavily involved in the
plans for the future of the town I'm
sure he would be proud to look at the
town today and recognize that many of
the good things that have happened are
down to his legacy Thank You Jenna thank
you Thank You chair
home I did not know Stuart very well but
I found him friendly accessible and easy
to talk to and he will be a sad loss for
the town they determine those words from
our three counselors I'm sure
encapsulate the memories that many of us
have of Stuart and therefore I'd now
like to move that this the counsel notes
for the regret the death of former
counselor B's counselor for Stratford
Alveston ward from 2002 to 2010 and
chairman of the Council for 2007-2008
and we extended sympathy to his family
and friends in their loss thank you
ladies and gentlemen
I now move on to the recent death of
counselor Eric Payne an eric of course
was a sitting counselor at the time he
died in october and so we all have had
an opportunity to work with eric and
what a highly respected and conscience
conscientious counselor eric was not
only here but also in his beloved
hometown of also austere quiet
unassuming but with a common sense
approach to issues and problems he was
always ready to listen even to us
younger and less measured counselors and
in response his replies and comments
what all was well thought through
logical and a sound his devotion to
public service over so long a period was
a standing and with that service came a
wealth of experience even now I'm sure
many of us as I do might stopping to
think what would Eric say I miss Eric
and I'd like to thank him for his
devotion to this council thank you
Thank You chair that equals Deputy Chair
of overview and scrutiny committee when
I was chair
I thought Eric was very friendly very
helpful and utterly reliable I liked and
respected Eric he struck me as a true
gentleman he is a sad loss councillor
Adams and Thank You mr. chairman I first
started to work with Eric during his
second term with mayor of Oslo in 2006
the clerk of twenty thirty two years
gave his notice and with Eric at the
helm
we ran the Town Council and pointed a
very successful new clock by then
persuaded him to stand for the District
Council
we work together on all our residents
town's residents and tiles problems and
even after the wards split we continue
to discuss everything so much so that
some of the staff called a spell crew if
one of us was in the department the
other one wasn't far behind the last
time I saw Eric in hospital a week
before he died he was still concerned
that I'd sorted out a problem for one of
his residents that was the sort of man
he was always concerned about others he
belonged to so many organizations in the
town and he was mr. Ulster and our local
lad
the town missing the Mike and I have
lost a colleague and a very good friend
Thank You cousin wart
Thank You German chairman it's difficult
to pay a tribute to Eric when the most
fitting tribute of all I think was the
huge attendance at his funeral service
German when even the Lord left tenant of
the county has to stand at the back of
the church because of lack of space and
when there are crowds outside who can't
even get into the church you know
there's something special going on Eric
was one of those people who relied on
action rather than words he'll be
remembered as a huge contributor to the
life of Ulster and I can well recall
that on many occasions when I visited
the time Eric was to be seen doing some
basic helpful tasks in the time just
like picking up little whatever it was
to keep the town attractive he was a
tireless worker for the time and on this
cancer was a resolute defender of the
town's interests chairman it's people
like Eric who keep our communities
taking over and Ulster will be the
perler for his absence
councillor Barnes
just a few words about a great guy
we had our differences it from him for
number of years but one thing that I did
do I'm honest I took him to the Bulldog
bash to open it with me
when I was chairman of the County
Council he had a wonderful day I've just
spoken to his wife they've still got the
photos plague day so hopefully he will
remember that plus all the help he's
given Ulster and everybody else Thank
You counselor get us a thank you Jim
from a personal perspective eric was
responsible for the start of my
political interest because I won't
remember the day when councillor Adams
and councilor pain shimmered up to me
one day and said to me how do you fancy
running for the county Mike and I
suspect in many ways that was the
beginning of my political aspiration and
he grew to be a great friend and a great
supporter and a great person to go for
to for advice and I realized pretty
early on with Eric this he wasn't
actually political at all and in many
ways I suspect he wasn't actually really
a member of the Conservative Party he
was a member of officers community and
he always realized that the important
role that he undertook was one of
representing that community and the
politics behind it wasn't actually that
significant or important it's very
difficult to try and put a list of the
things to which Eric was responsible for
but you know also suffered from flooding
for many many years
Ulster oak sue I and Eric in particular
we worked very very hard Eric was a
great one for standing at the front of
the community and looking for every
opportunity to find ways which he could
reduce the suffering of those people
that he he actually represented and in
many many other areas within the actual
structure the community himself he was a
bell ringer as a member
you know he was you know mr. flowers and
bloom along with his beautiful wife
Margaret who was mrs. flowers in bloom
as it were in charge of the floral
displays within the community bowls it
was a wonderful wonderful wonderful time
and as I was sitting here I just before
I really sort of sang too many words
because I knew Susan already really
capsulated it well I thought she went
over to I guess a fourth member of the
Ulster clan it was an unofficial member
of the of the trio as it were Sir
William Lawrence who calls tree sadly
lost as well but he was a great friend
of Eric's as well and I'm sure that he
would reflect everything that's been
said here about him in today as well so
I guess I just finally say the teaser it
was a truly great man and he'll be well
respected and he'll be truly lost within
the community of Ulster now and into the
future
thank you Joe it is cuz the saint
chairman there have been many themes in
the last three or four tributes that of
honesty hard-working cheerfulness always
ready to listen and above all a grand
servant to Ulster in so many ways and I
don't know that I can add to that but I
can bring in one extra that I think is
quite important we say he's a sad loss
but I feel I've lost a friend and nobody
else has described him as that why
shouldn't we describe Eric Payne as a
friend of members of this council and a
friend of this council as well as a true
friend to Ulster because I don't recall
when I was in Ulster seeing Eric picking
up litter I do see him remember seeing
him wandering around the town with a
spade in his hand and by somebody else
pushing a wheelbarrow just to help you
know for him for something to do with
the Spade
and I'm glad that that's brought a few
smiles to people's faces because that
was certainly Eric's characteristic and
we heard at his funeral I managed to
squeeze into a seat in the church that
day and only just but we did hear about
the tributes to him along a similar vein
his work as a building er his service to
the church and indeed his faith and
purpose within that community of Ulster
and I agree he will be sadly missed but
I would like to sort of say to everybody
here that I think I lost a friend when
Eric went I also like councillor Adams
to go and see him in hospital and I
don't remember he spoke to me about jobs
in Oster not that day but he did pick up
he picked up something very interesting
to me he talked about his offspring
being in eaten so Kinnear Sania's
and I remember eating the silica because
my grandfather used to live instant ice
which is not far from there and used to
have friends in that area and would tell
me about them with some fiction so
anyhow that was a link which I found
quite valuable to remember and that
would be my passing memory of Eric apart
from the fact that when he was in charge
of the scrutiny committee and I was a
member of it I seem to recall we had
some of the shortest meetings that we've
ever possibly had nobody else has
mentioned that have they but anyway I
think that that I don't say that to him
disrespecting me he was efficient he got
on with the business he made certain
that we all had time to say what we
wanted and then he moved on to the next
item so effectively I don't say that
disrespectfully but in all I would like
very much to join in with the tributes
to Eric and feel very positive about him
as a member of this council so Thank You
councillor Saint
our council cargle Thank You chairman oh
thank you
well I seem to remember everything most
of my life and you know the first time I
seem to remember him now the Conway trio
when he was on the stage doing miming to
to various acts and answered like and
the last we used to have and I think
that typifies Eric
he always had a laugh yeah how does such
a sense of humor moving on I think I
can't forget us obviously learned a
little bit from Eric and he sidled up to
me and asked if I wouldn't stand to
district but I will say that Eric was so
supportive he was out every time we're
campaigning and knocking on doors and
delivering leaflets tirelessly every
single time so I really remember those
those times with him
it's a sad loss and here's a friend as a
council Saint said the great loss to us
all thank you thank you I'm sure we all
support and understand those words about
Eric and we miss him I therefore I think
is appropriate now to move on once again
the council notes who regrets the death
of our councilor Eric Payne counselor
for Ulster town war 2007 to 18 and chair
of the council in 1112 and we extended
send our sympathy to his family and
friends in their loss are we agreed
thank you
moving on then to item 6 on the agenda
as will all know council Williams has
not been well I did speak to him on
Saturday and he regrets not being with
us today and I know he's spoken to other
campuses as well but we are required to
ask custom Ferrell to raise the matter
of participants
Thank You chairman section 85 brackets
form of the Local Government Act 1972
requires a member to attend at least one
meeting of the authority within a
six-month consecutive period unless a
further request has been made and
considered by the full council to extend
the usual six-month rule the added
governance and democracy has received a
request that council williams be allowed
an extension first requirement enabling
him to remain in office due to illness
counsel Williams has been unable to
attend any meeting of the council since
the six of July 2018 Carol needs to
consider this request before the end of
the six-month period which would it be
the fifth of January 2019 if not he
would cease to be a member of the
authority due to his illness I would ask
the council to approve the
recommendation on page 17 of your papers
and at the same time which council
Williams a speedy recovery Thank You
chairman does anybody wish to comment on
that in which case I can I assume that
is agreed thank you
we now move on to the rather silent mr.
Webb earlier comment it is of course an
end of an era and you may wonder why
there are two Dave's up there I would
assure you we are only talking about the
figure on the left hand as you're
looking at this but I thought have a
great picture of the our senior
executive team after 43 years we will
miss T Dave and it is unfortunate I've
really got to know him over the past
eight months what I have discovered
there in those months is a man of
immense experience a gentle but firm
hand on the rudder steering us in this
council through uncertain and without
doubt challenging times he took on his
new role some three years ago following
a major change in the structure and
senior manager with its council and
there was so little disruption that we
scarcely knew a change had taken place
although clearly it had mr. Webb with
his care executive director David
alongside him was in charge it was a
change well made and I know Dave steady
leadership has been well received by
staff counselors and our customers one
only has to look at officience
successful ranking of his council under
his leadership in survey after survey to
realize how well it has been run under
his guidance
despite the owner of staska being
executive director dave has always been
a man who's had a time to speak and help
others be there members of staff or
councillors a cheery and genuine smile
and sound advice I know it did not take
long after my election as your chairman
Dave taught me a quiet a much
appreciated word in my ear just the
faintest of jets a suggestion of how
things might be easier if I did it this
way or that not demanding but just
helpful advice as one of his counsels
younger chairman and obviously less
experienced that guidance was not really
much needed but much appreciated
thank you Dave I'll continue to heed
that advice and remember it sauce in
times to come even though I can't pop up
pop up
see one last thing as you won't be here
for your next anniversary I thought as
appropriate as we did give a certificate
in early wrong but we should actually
give a stuff go to mr. Webb 43 years as
counsel however I'm sure I'm not alone
our counselors if I go to leader first
and then counselor mores Thank You chair
it certainly does seem like the end of
an era
like the chair over the past eight
months I've been increasingly impressed
with Dave and that's from a very high
start point I found him very easy to
work with relaxed easygoing yet always
on top of things
he was always in charge his advice was
always sound and insightful I valued it
highly indeed my role would have been
very difficult without the honest and
open way Dave operated I think dave has
huge integrity he's not only respected
by staff and counselors but he's
critical in setting the tone for the
whole council what became ever more
apparent as I worked with external
bodies was how highly Dave he's
respected by his peers
he's more influential than I think we
have recognized Dave we will miss you
and I personally will miss you I wish
you all the best for the future and I
hope you're formidable talents do not go
to waste
council most Chairman thank you chairman
Dave is one of those people he's been at
this council even longer than me so I
can remember him in a variety of roles
and now he's made it to the top he's
decided to retire have I can honestly
say that in all the various roles in
which I encountered Dave he was
unfailingly helpful we didn't always
crack all the problems but I knew that
Dave's advice would be sound
and that he had the experience to
understand all the issues and chairman
the job is not as simple as many people
think and local government comes in for
a lot of criticism as I'm sure Dave
would agree but without people like Dave
I'm sure there would be even more
critics and I'm particularly pleased
about the way that Dave has made efforts
to communicate and get involved in the
wider community and I'm sure this will
stand this council in good stead in the
years to come Dave I imagine you'll want
to keep in touch with what happens but
you've now got the benefit of being able
to watch proceedings on the webcast
rather than sitting at the front and
that means Dave you can miss all the
boring bits so thank you again for your
help it's much appreciated thank Council
Morse council of Audrey if I was put on
record I think probably that my most
enjoyable time of this council was when
I had the transport housing portfolio
and worked closely with Dave
I thought we achieved a lot I'm really
proud of what we did it was a privilege
to work with you it was a as you know
often critical about local government
but it was a pleasure working with you
in that period I thank you for that I
will fondly remember those times thank
you ladies and gentlemen I know
despite being silent earlier on when he
was expected to make comments mr.
Webster now decided to break forth into
song today and I think I'm very quickly
clear in the room if I break forth into
song
[Laughter]
now I deliberately didn't want to making
a nice because I knew this items on the
agenda but I just like to brought and
record my thanks to all the members here
for all the health support advice of
work with some absolutely great
portfolio holders I can't myself
incredibly lucky to have worked with
such a great bunch of councillors not
just those who were here but lots of the
people are on the board and people like
Eric Payne Stewart bees whoo-hoo
remembered earlier something like nearly
half of my life has been in this castle
which is an extraordinary period of time
I'd also like to thank David Buckland
because the the relationship where is a
genuine partnership and it's not down to
meets tend to both of us and we took
over at the counselor a very difficult
time there was a lot of stuff that we
had to do to to improve our reputation
and engage and I was really grateful for
getting the opportunity to be executive
director ahead of paid service so you
cancel the science sitting down there I
remember him telling me that I got the
job is absolutely gobsmacked but really
enjoyed the last two to three years
sorry it's coming to an end but new
passages new but I'm really grateful to
everybody say thank you all
now there's a gentleman who such an
orthodox at this point but we've
probably expected that of me I know one
of the groups in this room have already
made a presentation to Dave at an
earlier date but as we as one of the
other groups and a substantial number of
us are here today I'm Chris Mills would
you like to come forward a little
something for you from one of the other
groups
right if we never we've gone to 0.8 or
68 the petition for the people's vote as
the petition which I have here contains
over a thousand signatures our published
scheme for dealing with these matters
automatically requires a dissipate or
discussion full counsel and therefore
inviting mr. Baker who is here to come
forward to present his petition mr.
Baker as we discussed earlier on we you
have five minutes would you like to come
here and if you could press the red
button or the button on the micro until
the red light comes on chairman
councillors members of the public I'd
like to thank you for this opportunity
to speak on behalf of 1000 Stratford
constituents who signed a petition
calling on the council to support of
people's vote national humiliation
miserable failure brexit broken Britain
UK a laughingstock Civil War national
crisis not my words but some
descriptions of the current political
situation taken from yesterday's press
councilors I don't think anyone can say
with conviction that brexit is going
well two years on for the 2016
referendum the country is more divided
than ever the ruling party is on the
brink of Civil War with a third of its
MPs refusing to back its own leader and
Parliament seems totally incapable of
taking back control worse we have to
shake ourselves to remember that the
situation we are in is not the result of
a natural disaster a global global
economic disaster and or even another
country declaring war on us it is
entirely self-inflicted who would have
thought that we would be approaching the
cliff edge of the 29th of March 2019
with no idea of our destination no idea
about our future or even any idea what
sort of country we want Britain to be
although the Prime Minister continues to
stick determinately to her withdrawal
agreement it is clear it will never gain
the support of her own party never mind
a majority in parliament it is clear as
well that's stumbling off the cliff edge
of the 29th of March with no deal no
plan in place and no transition period
would be an unmitigated national
disaster certainly every party in
Parliament opposes this other
alternatives like the Norway solution or
Canada plus are not even on the table
would not be in the national interest
and there is no time now to negotiate
them meanwhile the turmoil brexit is
inflicted on the country is poisoning
our communities turning neighbor against
neighbor and giving a license to every
extremist I'm sure your hearts like mine
sink at the daily news bulletins of the
growing intolerance in our nation and
the breakdown in our long-held
traditional British values proud
Britannia weeks for us our local economy
too is already being damaged only
yesterday Jaguar Land Rover the largest
single employer in the district
announced that it was axing up to 5,000
jobs to combat brexit and the falling
sales our local tourist and agricultural
industries are suffering too as they
struggle to recruit a workforce staff
shortages in our local NHS and care
sector are adding additional burdens
when the need for the services they
provide to an aging population escalate
with the situation we are now in it is
becoming increasingly clear that whether
you support remain or leave there is
only one option now remaining to us
councillors it may not have been your
original wish but the time has come to
put parties country before party before
self and to put the question of
Britain's relationship with the European
you
- the people to decide the only viable
course of action left to us is for
Parliament to delay article 50 and to
seek the informed consent of the people
for the future direction of this nation
this informed consent will have the
advantage of the facts and not be based
on the misleading rhetoric from both
sides the referent referendum debate of
two years ago already there is strong
evidence that the people of Stratford
who you represent are in favor of this
92% of both levers and remain errs in
recent polls in Stratford supported such
a people's vote more is it undemocratic
to go back to the people a second time
now we know the reality of what brexit
actually means
councillors the call is on us to bring
our fractured democracy back together a
people's vote is the only option that
stands a chance of doing this what true
Denmark Democrat would not accept the
outcome of a free and fair vote future
generations will judge us severely if we
miss this opportunity councillors
consider you will need to look your
children in the eye and your
grandchildren and their children and in
all conscience be able to say in good
faith I put the interests of Stratford
and my country first in order to provide
you with the safe secure and prosperous
future
I've enjoyed in the last 50 years
councillors 40 councils including
Birmingham have already supported it a
similar petition and I follow 1000
signatories now urge you to think in
their example thank you the same in
Stratford thank you very much
[Applause]
right Thank You mr. Becker before I call
on members to speak I'm gonna invite the
monitoring officer mr. Grafton
to explain constitutional issue which we
need to understand Thank You chairman
those members who here in this chamber
at our last council meeting on the 15th
of October will recall that there was a
motion before the council on a very
similar basis to the question put in the
petition the the exact wording was that
the council calls on the government to
abandon any plans for a hard brexit and
to give the British people a vote on
whatever deal they finally get the
significance of that is that at the
meeting Council rejected that motion for
members of the public the the council
has rules that determine how we debate
matters in Council today and one of
those rules are all 18.2 states that
once a motion has been before counts I
mean it's been rejected then generally
you can't bring the matter back for
another decision until at least six
months has passed and of course we're
still within that period having said
that there is another rule in the
Constitution that allows other rules to
be suspended for the duration of the
meeting the net result of all of that is
as things stand at the moment you can
speak and debate the issue if you like
to but you can't actually reach a
decision which would respond to the
petition may I propose that Standing
Orders are suspended Thank You Cosimo's
do you have a seconder for that the
forecheck I think caught my eye first
but we have a request or proposal that
the rules are suspended as described by
monitoring officer
all those in favor of suspending the
rules
all those against suspending the rules
18 those judgment it's the council's
decision not to decide to suspend the
rules on this occasion however that we
still have the 15 minutes to for members
to raise issues and given this is a
contentious issue what I've proposed is
that those in favor of the wish you've
set out in the petition have seven
minutes to speak and then those against
the proposal set out in the petition
have seven minutes to speak and thereby
we'll get an equitable hearing of both
sides so it is up to those speaking for
or against to decide as to whether
they're speaking for the entire seven
minutes or whether they will let their
colleagues have a say - we are limited
to 15 minutes by our Constitution mr.
Chairman I suppose we wouldn't have been
limited to 15 minutes had we suspended
Standing Orders not a great day for
democracy if I may say chevon but
perhaps you can give us some guidance
are you taking all the speakers in favor
first and then all the speakers against
or are you alternating halves of also I
think the easiest way of dealing with
this is to have seven minutes for those
people to make that point one way and
then seven minutes to make the point the
other way and then our leader won't be
exhausted trying to work out whether
who's halves of them and who hasn't has
seven minutes so if everybody's happy
with that
seven minutes one way and then seven
minutes the other do I have consensus on
that thank you
in which case how's the most do we shall
open the battery we can surf Rajini
wishes to open chairman kalsa fracturing
seven minutes starts now
thank you I had to cast the water lake
as well
I hope to be very brief Pandora's box
was carelessly even recklessly opened by
David Cameron on the 23rd of June 2016
and outpolled EU problems at Maggie
Thatcher John Major and other moderate
conservatives had managed or just about
managed in the interests of stability of
our nation for many many years we are
now overwhelmed on all sides by near
trees lies half lies wishful thinking's
and a phobia dissembling stubbornness
and I must say on my part despair our
representative representative democracy
appears to be incapable of taking
control and give the leadership this
divided nation desperately needs if I
MPs do not give that leadership we need
another way to move forward
luckily left at the bottom of Pandora's
Box fragile slim hope hides time to
release hope and allow the public to
express their view on the way forward
we're in such a dangerous quagmire
democracy itself demands that the
population now give their considered
view on the options our elected
representatives cannot agree on events
do not stand still views more democracy
must serve the population thank you
Thank You Joseph actually
councillor Vaudrey I think it's
important that people know this as a
cross-party group they're going to speak
in favor it's not just you know I'm
disappointed how many Tories won't speak
in favour I also want to reiterate the
comments made by the original speaker
that because this is why we're speaking
at Stratford district councillors how
important is locally because of the
uniqueness of Jaguar Land Rover this
announced this laying off staff now
because of the food and beverage
industry because the tourism industry
because properly councillor food check
and I probably have more East Europeans
in our wards than anyone else you know
the whole issue I remember a couple
years ago we were debating the issue
about rising crime on the back of that
and when I get into that issue about how
foreigners are being treated in these
days and their lack of
respect it did concern me the other day
that mystery Smaug who probably have
made two big decisions in the last last
couple of months one failed when he
initially challenged the prime minister
the second one saying a 67 percent
majority should lead to a resignation
described experts including the governor
of the Bank of England as a sort of
failed Canadian there was no need to
call him Canadian I say this is someone
who is a dual citizen of Canada it was
racism to describe him as Canadian
nothing less from racism and it really
disappointed me that he felt he had to
lower himself to that level I'm a
remainer I want to have you know we are
in a quagmire and they will ask
Parliament to be in this mess
I'd rather article 50 get cancelled and
we go back to the minor fee but I have
one final point to make in terms of the
issue we have people like Jacob Riis MOG
saying you can't trust the experts on
our side they will fail look at how you
know it wasn't a collapse after the the
last vote
you have himself proposing purporting to
have his own experts on his side but I
have to say by the same logic there was
absolutely equal and opposite risk I
would say even more but if you get a
situation like a No Deal we could be in
a catastrophic situation so if you
discount experts on both sides you are
left with one intellectually common
position which is doing nothing is the
right thing to do because you don't
trust anyone on either side so I think
at least this way if we can put the
elements to the people and we can ask
them to decide at least that way we know
we can truly live by our decisions thank
you cuz of watching the 2016 referendum
gave this government and mandates a
negotiated brexit deal and two years on
no one likes what to reason mates come
back with and at the moment we have
either a bad deal or no deal and that
affects residents of Stratford so what
next
No Deal we will know how kilometers
that's going to be the public will never
forgive the politicians if we leave with
no deal economically it will be a
disaster particularly for this
particular area with our reliable being
reliable on the hotel trade and we
as mentioned by Council of oratory jlr
as well the solution is to go back to
the people and give them the democratic
right now we have more of the facts to
make a decision to proceed or to remain
in Europe brexit will Jen will affect
generations to come
as Jonathan Baker has said and our
politicians at the moment do not have
the capacity to decide what to do
therefore we need to go back to the
people and just one other thing I think
to suspect not to suspend the going
forward and to not have a proper debate
today was was very sad sad for Stratford
District Council Thank You councillor
Patrick those I come for two minutes to
go two minutes ago if there's no other
speakers be I will speak chairman but
I'm quite willing to give away to
somebody else who hasn't had a say so
far in which case I'll I'll take the two
minutes chairman chairman we heard mr.
Baker give us yes earlier some quote
from some quotes from yesterday's press
I'd like to follow on in that vein and a
couple of quotes from this week's
economists their editorial States thirty
months after the British voted to leave
the European Union the country's
cultural divisions are more entrenched
than ever the result of two years of
hand-wringing has been to confirm the
two sides low opinion of each other a
chairman it's difficult to disagree with
that and as far as I can see neither
side has made any progress in convincing
the error the other of the error of
their ways and to rank a chairman I
can't see that anything will change that
and but something has to happen just to
avoid the economic disaster of crashing
out with no deal so we need to try to
start to get some sort of consensus on
the way forward chairman this petition
puts forward the only possible way that
I can see for moving forward
we now all know much more about the
processes in
locations have leaving the EU than we
did before if we have another vote on
the options then at least we can say
that whatever decision is reached people
voted for it in the knowledge of the
implications of that vote which
certainly did not apply the first time
round chairman at the moment the
remainders are saying the levers won the
referendum because they lied and the
levers say the remainders are ignoring
the will of the people
Gemma I can't see any other democratic
way forward there another vote on all
the options so I'm very happy to support
the proposals and aims of this petition
Thank You Jimmy thank you
there's 8 seconds left to go so I prefer
first at that point I will of course in
the interests of equality who wishes to
speak against the motion that the
proposals in the petition councillor
Perry Thank You chair I'll be very brief
it is my view that this is a national
issue and we need to be reminded that 52
percent of our residents across the
district voted to leave I will leave it
at that
well you could have eight seconds if you
wish councillor it is I wasn't really
going to say a great deal of them that
really just to reflect calcifiers views
I reminded myself what the question was
that was put to the nation on the 23rd
of June in 2016 he said simply this vote
once should the United Kingdom remain a
member of the European Union or leave
the European
that was the simple question and the two
responses were I remain a member of the
European Union or leave the European
Union and the country decided on the
latter on leave the European Union
there's a democratic decision whether
whether we like that decision or not
thank you kind of because legatus
does anybody Kyle Richards Thank You
chair I will agree with the my speaking
my first speakers that respondent head
of me in 2016
we did have a people's vote we the
entire UK population were addressed and
they were asked to vote whether they
should remain or leave the EU liking
majority they chose to leave the EU we
need to honor that it was a free and
fair vote at that time what I would
remind people I said much of what I
would otherwise say in our October
meeting so you're already aware of my
views the only thing I would leave
members with is that in 2016 as a leave
voter I was accused by many remains as
being stupid idiot idiotic and
unintelligent as a member of the public
that voted and I was also told that all
levers were stupid idiotic and
unintelligent and yet now the very
people that were accusing us of being
stupid are asking effort - asking those
people to vote again on this topic we've
done the vote we've been through it a
decision was made and we need to stick
to that decision and all the national
government to continue to do what
they're doing by taking a vote and other
people's vote we are undermining their
position and their ability to negotiate
thank you thank you Richard
Cosmo Harris Thank You chair listening
to the conversations in the room today I
take your point it's a national issue
but to take council immortus point as
well to become involved in it means we
get gridlocked and deadlocked in
negotiations and we haven't got the
power to make any difference that way we
can't acknowledge what is happening and
support our residents in the best way we
but I don't think it's the place of this
council to be saying anything the other
thing is to come back to your point I
agree the sniping between parties is
unhelpful
it's disengaging our youth who we need
to hear clearly I have to say picking up
from the youth they're now voting
probably to leave based on the poor way
we've been treated by the EU can I also
point out your point about community
cohesion and the divisions in society
this is not due to the last two years
we've had these problems ongoing for
many years on different successive
governments of lucking to deal with
these issues and hence we got grexit
thank you I haven't spotted any other
councillor soon
germán I'm assuming that we're in the
seven minutes down and not the eight
seconds yeah I personally think that I
have stomach or we walk counts the
Harris has just said if we had another
vote would that really be decisive I
can't see it because you'd have to know
what the question ought to be to
effectively get any meaningful solution
from it and I'm very much I'm very
doubtful as as so as to whether that
that would indeed be be possible I think
it's a little bit of in graciousness of
council of Audrey who I would normally
regard as my friend and I didn't realize
he was part Canadian I understood that
he grew up in the same part of England
as me so that was just act knowledge so
consequently that certainly wasn't
anything to do with Canada either but
anyway the situation is that Jaguar Land
Rover our effect lying off staff not in
this district but by moving that by
manufacturer discovery to Slovakia the
discoveries are built at Solihull
therefore although it does affect
British workforce
it doesn't affect this district and I
think that the work that we're doing
with Jaguar Land Rover in the
development of a research base our
gayden it's not planned to have any
major change I can't see that at all
there might be something I hadn't heard
that's come about but the effectively I
don't think that that that that
workforce basic gayden is going to be
varied in any particular way so
therefore we have a situation whereby
shall we this is a national problem not
a local problem and although we probably
can act to effect
local residents I think by imposing
another national vote on people or
supporting it is really quite
counterproductive and I think quite
frankly it's not something that we
should entertain at this point in time
even the mistress of misjudgment the
Prime Minister has effectively ruled it
out let's hope that wasn't another
misjudgment of hers but anyway the
situation is that you know we've had a
number of issues there where things have
gone off on one direction and moved into
another but we've had a deal worked out
for us and the problem is and I hate to
say this and I'm certainly not against
the Canadians but there seems to be an
awful lot of French people dealing with
the negotiations between Britain on the
behalf of the EU now that I think is a
serious issue because the point of the
matter is the French want our money
you could sigh and gasp as much as you
like but this is the truth of 15 seconds
Cancer Center 15 seconds is it right
well I'll try and wind up in okay so
basically we all had four hours finished
by arguing effectively that we need some
form of deal to put to the people and we
certainly haven't got it at the moment
Thank You counsel Satan that is custom
all sigh Apollo three seconds over but
other than that so we've had an equal
amount of time arguing in favor and
against and I think there has been a a
wide range of views obviously they
conflict or in many respects some of the
views conflicted with those of others so
we did have a decision that we have not
now taking a formal vote on that so
which point I propose to draw section
eight to a close moment could I just
suggest that we give our thanks to those
that organized this petition this is the
first debate of this I can recall and I
appreciate the time and effort they've
taken to bring this to the council I'm
sure we've all support the efforts that
you have made and so thank you for that
which I'm just going to wait for a few
minutes if we just stop the clock as it
were for those who wish to leave
therefore move on to point 9 public
participation question by the public we
have one question from mr. Mick love in
connection with the period pavilion
you've had a response mr. love from
councillor organ do you have any
secondary question to that place Jim and
I assumed that he can make a few
introductory comments as normal before
he puts his question absolutely
good afternoon chairman and councilors
my name is Mickel of former mayors
ruffled up on I even and a strap for
daeun born in IVA someplace in 1934 my
mother was also born in usual place in
ninth in 1898 and often as a child or
mother would ride with Marie Corelli in
a horse and trap ran the town ears on
she would continue to speak highly of
the grand lady and tell me of her many
of our good deeds it is very well
documented that Marie Corelli spent a
great deal of her own funds towards the
restoration are not keep of key
buildings in stratford-on-avon
including new place she purchased the
first garden in 1910 and subsequently
requested this area to the residents of
stratford-upon-avon with a plaque in the
gardens confirming that the area as an
open space for the benefit of the town
it is also well known that Stratford
Borough Council where at that time made
custodians of that land if they were
custodians then the Stratford District
Council are custodians now and have
guilty care and protect the land for the
purpose for which it was generously
donated over a hundred years ago my
question is why did the Stratford
district council decide to site the
pavilion in the fair's garden without
any consultation with the residents of
Stratford on AIM given that the first
garden was given to the people of
Stratford Milliken should consider
finding and more appropriate site before
going before going before the Planning
Committee in January or is this an
already done deal and qzm
mr. love you've received a response from
councilor organ on that I believe what I
also do you have a supplementary
question to her to her response or have
you you have content with what you said
the questions he's just asked so
identical to those set out in his
original question I would like to
comment on your response if I make right
is it could you make it a question
rather than up we need to have a
thoughtful mature question if it comes
to organ to respond to well I can make
it that way
yeah okay do you have a supplementary
question yes yes could you give us what
it is the response to the yeah the the
question the reverse punch that counts
again that this this council chose to
locate the the pavilion in the first
garden with a consulting the people
stuffin on Aven and that's the point of
knives all through you didn't know where
before we even went to planning you
decided that you were gonna put it in
the first garden and that you haven't
consulted the people are struck and I
know even before doing that that's the
point you're making
thank you
um thank you thank you for your question
and I do understand your concern
obviously whenever there is change of
any sort it does inspire emotions to
arise and we've just seen this in the
previous item um it's what comes first
is it the horse or the cart and I think
I've probably mix that metaphor up you
look at a location and then you seek to
ascertain whether it is suitable by way
of the planning process and within the
planning process is the consultation
process with the public and this is what
is actually in process now but I just
have to say it is ironic that the Town
Council have not actually objected to
this in the public consultation process
thank you all right thank you
if we move then on to the next item on
the agenda
Wright's point point turn constitutional
update committee procedure rules to the
point seven call upon the leave the
council to present his report Thank You
chair at its heart this is quite a
simple proposal it's a change intended
to do properly what counsel intended it
clarifies the rule of Ward chair of ward
members and does not leave as open to
legal challenge which they previously
wording up to now actually does and I
believe that the wording as it stands at
the moment has caused confusion about
the role of ward members the
recommendation is that the proposed
changes to the wording of committee
procedure rule 11 seven are set out in
the appendix to this report is a proof
immediate adoption and the monitoring
office of the authorized to amend the
Constitution of accordingly are we
agreed counselor said no Chairman I
disagree and I was just trying to
quickly look up to see whether or not
you had actually responded to the email
correspondence I included you in my I
can respond to that mr. st. I replied to
you on the day I received it well
unfortunately I haven't received that
now the situation is this quite simple
the decision that was made being council
in February of this year was effectively
a well-meaning decision it was not
something that we should just sort of
toss to one side and say we got it wrong
simply because somebody has come out
with this oh it's subject to legal
challenge now we all know that members
of this council are very concerned about
Appeals and therefore the risk of
Appeals
and this is what's coming to emphasize
in this particular report from mr.
Grafton now I think that the leader and
mr. Grafton should respect the decision
of Council to put it in and you yourself
should do so as well because at the time
if you remember we had two rather
difficult group meetings of the
conservative group where I was chairing
it whereby people were not contained
with various issues of planning and the
result was the proposal that came before
council in February and that decision
was made now we might have exceeded the
six months as a situation but I for one
even if I'm the only one in this council
I've got a vote against this proposal
this afternoon
for the simple reason that I think the
reason that the proposal that you're now
attempting to change was made by full
council and therefore should be
respected members decisions should carry
some respect and authority and not just
be told or members be told that we got
it wrong and the reason being is quite
simple you know mr. chair members you
were involved with an awful lot of
personal discussions with me and had
been since in the way that you have been
treated at planning committee meetings
you know from certain advice that's been
given to the meeting whereby you have
been constrained and the reason that
there was more than just the local
member involved in that decision-making
was because we were concerned about
facts being correct and it was thought
that the correction of facts was down a
little bit more than just to the wall
member there could be other people
involved in that consultation but
effectively knew the precise answer to
certain issues
that could not be otherwise resolved at
a planning committee meeting where in my
view it was essential to have the
correct facts before us and that's why I
think that the decision that was made
last February should be left in place
it's quite simple it's very
straightforward as councillor Jefferson
says this is very simple it is a bit
simple yes don't alter it Thank You
German I'm just going to respond to that
because castle st. I did address all
your concerns in my email to you and
it's unfortunately you haven't responded
as council Jefferson made clear in his
points early wrong and I will repeat
what I said to you in that email is that
the council motion approved in February
was not entirely reflected in the change
to the Constitution that was actually
put through what you proposed did not
actually happen you were sitting on the
Planning Committee when I representing I
think councillor Mills is Ward in fact
quested to speak again as council Mills
was absent and owing to the correct
interpretation by the solicitor
attending that planning meeting was
prevented from speaking again because of
the way your amendment had actually been
drafted in the Constitution itself not
in the motion that was approved and
therefore as a result and you then
raised the issue that you thought had
been addressed in the amendment and were
told by the look the lawyer no we
therefore had to address your and my
concerns which we shared to correct an
anomaly as to how it have been drafted
all we are doing here is correcting that
anomaly to return the Constitution to
what this council intended in February
and which you spent a lot of time
successfully working towards so we're
not setting aside your proposal that was
approved
we were actually ensuring that the
Constitution does reflect that change
because owing to an interpretation which
was read out by that solicitor in the
meeting clearly it was not clear so it
used word twice at that time were
seeking to clarify that amendment not
change it Casimir's Gemma this sounds
like an internal dispute within the
conservative group there are far too
many such disputes for us to start
considering them at council meetings can
I said yes we move on Thank You
councillor Morse was to said you did
raise your question please take account
of what mr. Morse has said but if you
wish to make one more point I find it
remarkable chairman that you should
admit that the Constitution was drafted
in a way that was incompatible with a
decision of counsel surely the mechanism
to change it would not be have a new
decision of counsel but to amend the
Constitution correctly Thank You mr.
suit I think in which case we need clear
to have a vote on this matter all those
in favor of the amendment anyone all
those against the amendment the motion
is carried
I'm sorry start again orgonite point 11
an organizational development strategy
18 to 20 I call a common councilors
Jefferson and organ to present this
report Thank You chairman
the council's staff strategy has not
been reviewed since 2013 the peer
challenged suggested that the review
should look at the development needs of
existing staff as well as assessing
skills knowledge and capacity gaps for
the future in addition to taking this
into account it has been developed using
stakeholder panels and best practice the
resulting draft strategy sets out what
is required of staff and counselors in
terms of leadership behavior and
engagement to deliver the council's
vision and ambition in addition it
specifies actions which need to be
prioritized in order to effect change it
has been through formal consultation
with the Cabinet employment and
appointments committee joint
consultation and negotiating group and
the leaders meeting and the
recommendation is that it is formally
adopted thank you thank you so much
raising issues on this where are we
agreed thank you
moving on to point 12 independent
remuneration panel members announced
review lights tax review now we do have
the leader of the IRP with us today who
said he's happy to come forward if there
any questions from members about his
process he would like to come forward
that the very kind I'm mr. Grafton
modern officer wishes beg for it just to
point out that in the implications boxes
at the back of the report there's some
wording about financial implications I
just want to make clear that in fact the
panel did not recommend indexing of
counselor allowances for this year
contrary to what it says in the
financial implications box
does anybody have any questions they
wish to write Thank You mr. fielding yes
I'm based around the mileage allowance
you have on occasion said to me that I
should go and inspect all the sites for
planning and as I'm on planning East and
also subbing on West and on licensing it
is important that we get round and look
at what is going to be presented before
us I believe that the mileage allowance
should take into account that retinas
necessary well miss SOT to make sure
that we do a good job it is only at the
moment when there is an inspection
organised by the chair of a particular
or the chair of the committee and
meeting the various officers on site
I consider that it should be more
flexible than that I'd also like to
point out that there is a problem with
regards to the definition of which
committees I'm on it's been somewhat
difficult to be on planning East but
also subbing on planning East I can't be
in two places at once even though I try
very hard Thank You the council fielding
Jewish Jewish respond yep on the the
definition of approved Duty for claiming
mileage I refer you to paragraph 23 and
our reports the panel's always operated
on the basis that claiming mileage
allowance should not be self-generating
and if you we have nope there's no way
to check whether anybody's been on a a
site visit and and you could generate
site visits willy nilly we just don't
know so therefore we've stuck to the
traditional and historical definition
I've approved
just as defined by the legislation we're
no longer bound by the legislation but
we have stuck to that and that's we've
been in two places at one time I can't
help you without I'm sorry counselor and
having said that more seriously I mean
we do understand that the nature of the
planning is actually going to be
revisited and the planning arrangements
there's a medium-term system of super to
spend or short time system a slippage
has been put in place and it's something
the panel's going to look at at its next
review there's going to be a new panel
for a next review next year it's going
to be a full review where the whole
thing is going to be looked at in the
mix thank you thank you
any further questions for counsel
Vaudrey it's just actually follow up on
caster fielding support I've never
claimed mileage so doesn't really bother
me but but there is a thing a
distinction to be drawn between going on
an authorized visit on planning where if
you like the planning officers there and
a number of people turn up so clear
there are witnesses to it and going on
specular a different time I'll just say
that there are times where I think it
isn't an official planning thing that
you may want to in future consider
councillor Atkinson mm-hmm Thank You
Jamie this is an issue I've raised with
the panel before because I have read but
I can't quote it that members should not
be disadvantaged in claiming expenses
and should be dealt with on a similar
basis to officers therefore we do have
to go and see our residents not just on
planning issues but on others and for
dr. hall to describe it as willy-nilly
and lack of control really questions our
integrity which I must say I resent
any coastal Harris Thank You chair just
to follow on from your point
sounds like Kingston I agree I think
what forgot has been forgotten in the
mix is the large areas that we cover now
it's not just like walking to our local
parishes our local church our local
residents I cover from deathless bridge
up to Junction 12 on the motorway which
is quite a way so have no choice but to
drive and I think that should be
considered because family Jewish
speaking on juice I mean on a general
note there is an issue I think here in
instruct for migrant district council
regarding travel partly relating to the
size of the district and one of the
other issues is the change in the nature
of representation in the district but
again we made recommendations our light
touch not the light touch review
previously which we rejected so we
basically took a decision this time
there's going to be a full review in the
mix everything's going to be thrown into
mix next time around next year and that
probably is when it may be a good time
to actually to consider whether the
travel allowances should be looked at
but the panel still operates on the
principle that travel allowances it
should not be self-generative
it's not impeding on the integrity of
anybody by saying that it's actually
that's common sense and that's how
common business sense operates in the
public sector thank you very much that's
a Jefferson thank you thank you chair I
just endorsed what has already been said
that I think next year there will be a
full review and I think the timing of
that is right and I think there is an
illness on members to actually make
point to the panel that they think the
panel ought to consider so with that
I would have asked people to endorse the
recommendation council cargle thank you
very briefly of notes County Council do
allow traveling expenses to the parish
meetings so that so I can be added into
the mix next year Thank You Erica
Coghill I think there are no more points
then we we've had a proposal that we
should move to the motion all those in
favor of adopting the recommendation
agreed it goes against I think it's
carrot thank you very much
point number 13 change of parish
boundaries and I call on counselor will
its coverlets to democracy portfolio
holder to raise issues Thank You
chairman
in April 2008 een the council received a
joint letter from gayden parish council
light on his parish council light on
parish and Cheston and Kingston posh
meeting the letter requests at the
counter undertake a review in light of
the future development within this area
and consider the change in parish
boundaries plus of the governance of the
new development area which would be in
light of on Heath a parish council area
and that there been increase in parish
councils of light on these increasing
the numbers by three to eight counselors
and a light on parish council an
increase of one counselor counselor
taking that chuckle to eight following a
meeting of the audit and standards
committee in June that committee
recommended to full count in July that
the review be commenced which the four
council agreed to a consultation has
taken place with stakeholders as well as
consultation letters written to every
household within the appropriate civil
parishes comments have been received by
all four patch council meetings in
response there have been very few
general responses from residents it is
gratifying that the parish council
meetings have been a lot of thoughts in
the future and therefore with what is
about to happen within that area with a
devotee of getting lights on Heath I
hope this council goes through look at
the recommendations on page 69 and
approve them so these parishes can start
to look forward and plan for the extra
workload that they might have thank you
thank you so will anybody wish to raise
any items on that Oh
in which case are we agreed
there's gentlemen slight change here um
some of you might know it's got a
bandage on my hand I had an accident
this morning with some machinery now
have taken some painkillers they're not
working
I'm gonna try some different ones so I'm
just going to hand over to the vice
chairman for five minutes when I go and
find something else see if it works I
apologize
Keir ladies and gentlemen moving on to
item 14 community governance review but
is that and Henley and Arden I invite
councillor thermal as governance and
democracy portfolio holder to introduce
this item Thank You councillor thermal
Thank You chairman I will approach this
in two particular ways first of all in
my responsibility and in my portfolio
and secondly as the ward member at the
last full council meeting it was agreed
that the request by burr desert and
Hanlon Arden jointed Parish Council to
undertake a governance review but that
should proceed since that meeting every
single household has received a
consultation letter asking for their
views which would be accepted either by
phone email or opal letter system hawky
stakeholders were also been consulted it
is for this council to either consider
approving or not approving the community
governance review speaking as a ward
member besides might comment already
published in the papers like the last
item it is sad that so few residents
have responded even though the number of
responses are greater and in favoring
more in one direction than in the other
is that the response to general apathy
to politics or maybe have the residents
of both civil parishes more important
things to do
or are they all happy with the status
quo gem at the moment I will leave
anything else I wish to say and I've lit
up the floor through you Thank You
councillor thermal would anybody like to
speak on this council Atkinson parish I
know pretty well actually and reading
the report I must think 11 votes in
favor of the parish councils
cause they must be very dynamic however
let me just say that this council does
not approve the community governance
review for bow desert and andean arden
in light of the comments received as
part of the consultation process i asked
counsel to do we have a seconder council
thorough anybody else that would like to
speak on this no can we move to the vote
all those in favor of the motion and
those against that's carried
thank you ladies and gentlemen sorry
about that slice intermission the
executive director has given me
something so plan I won't feel a thing
after this serve like advice slip away
quietly you'll understand we now move on
to point 15 cetera appointments at
electoral functions and I'll ask the
leader to address this please Thank You
chair listen I think he's a routine
issue and it is the visibility Brian
storm is appointed as deputy returning
officer and deputy Electoral Officer as
from 1st of January 2019 Thank You chair
are we agreed right thank you on point
16 review of the bylaws Bancroft garden
staff on Haven and I invite council
organ portfolio holder for resources and
property art reduces item Thank You
chair the Bancroft gardens includes the
paved area called waterside which is
adjacent to the road named waterside the
bylaws were established in 1905 and they
are still valid if a little out of date
they do not permit vehicles at the
Bancroft gardens and this includes not
only motorcycles but for instance
mobility scooters they would be included
as they are classed as vehicles
motorcycles have historically parked at
Waterside and there are properly popular
gatherings of motorcycles on Wednesday
evenings many people like to promenade
to see the motorcycles however there has
been an official complaint that it
should not be allowed the matter of the
bylaws requires attention and to help
inform the council review of bylaws
cabinet has expressed the view that
organized motorcycle gatherings on the
council
land known as waterside is supported the
recommendation is for the council to
amend the terms of reference for the
regulatory committee to allow it to make
amend revoke and enforce in relation to
all bylaws and the council delegates the
review of bylaws for the Bancroft
gardens to the regulatory committee
Thank You cousin Ward Thank You chairman
sir I do have concerns about this and
it's not gives me it's not relating to
the Bancroft in particular it's relating
to the principle of who should be able
to change bylaws the regulatory
committee or any other committee and
comprises a small number of councillors
and it may well be that decisions are
taken our bylaws if we delegate them in
this way by members who have nothing to
do with the areas affected it seems to
me quite reasonable that the whole
council should have a say in bylaws
chairman and therefore I'm not
comfortable with this but do any other
councils wish to say all council organ
do you want to respond to that yes
chairman I think if council members are
of the same opinion as cancelling walls
that it should not be delegated to
regulatory committee then I am content
with that course of action it comes to
sent I'm pleased with that but I'm gonna
support Council and walls he didn't
support me earlier on but however I'm
going to support him on this occasion
because the responsibility for policy
issues and that includes the making of
bylaws rests with Council
I hesitate because I want mr. Grafton to
pay attention to what I'm saying right
oh it's mr. buck that was distracting
you was it I didn't spot that I do
apologize however the situation is this
as you know mr. Grafton you've often
spoken to me about this when we've had
discussions but the responsibilities for
policymaking are rest in certain areas
according to our Constitution and
respond the ultimate sanction on policy
rests with full council and we could
continue delegating things forever if
we're not careful and then the full
council have very little work to do so I
support that and I'm glad to hear that
counts are organized content with that
arrangement I don't think the matter
should be delegated to the regulatory
committee it should be a matter to refer
to full council for making of bylaws and
for council it effectively does make the
decisions that arrest with it counts of
Audrey I have sympathy with both
councillors saying to council Morse and
I just thought I suppose one question
I'm not aware this has come before
council but maybe it does come before
regular committee but if it is such an
infrequent occurrence it's not as though
an arguing that we could against it
would be there it's gonna overwhelm our
workload couldíve it's it was once in a
century then perhaps it's okay for it to
come to full council so I would be back
in council Morton councillor st. Thomas
come spirit Thank You chair as chairman
of the regulatory committee I would be
quite happy particularly as we have the
consensus from the portfolio holder to
agree with councillor Morse and would be
very happy on behalf the regulatory
committee if if such an important and
unique situation was to be considered by
full council I have a second of that
council Vaudrey all those in favor of
comes the Morse's as the monitoring
officer wishes to speak of course it's
completely up to you as for cat it's
completely up to you as full council on
whether you actually deal with the
bible's
or you delegate it to the committee the
sole reason that I'm recommending that
it goes to a committee is because the
review of bylaws is quite a complex and
long-winded process my my utmost thrust
behind the recommendation was not to
have long-winded processes and
complications with a group of 36 members
which I could say was going to be
potentially horrendous I have a counter
suggestion I hear what you say about a
small committee looking at it there are
there is the ability to delegate the
matter to a committee let's say the
regulatory committee and do all the work
and then for their recommendation to
come back to you
saving you all that business I really do
have concerns about us this won't be a
mom meeting this will be a series of
meetings and I don't want to block up
council business so I haven't made
myself clear enough in the report I'm
apologize for that but that's the sole
reason for it it is a map it is a
council function it's not the executive
side of the business that's absolutely
clear but as I say that was the reason
behind it provided the ultimate Kempton
thank you chair just following on from
that with council knows perhaps the
actual answer is that the recommendation
as an amendment that gives life to
bringing that review by the regulatory
committee back to full council to be
signed off so I think in terms of the
terms of reference allowed to make the
terms of reference of regulation rather
than delegating the reviews to the
regulatory committee that the regulatory
committee review and make a
recommendation back to full counts
and that would probably get us get us
through that if I can find some support
for that as a as an amendment then we'll
we can with proceed thank you I would be
more than happy to second that very
sensible recommendation which I think
would satisfy everyone in the room
because some also happy with that nice
Jess therefore that do we have a
proposal from councillor Pemberton
seconded by Councillor organ all those
in favor of that amended proposal thank
you
it's carried anybody against carried
over page to page anyway without point
17 minute 44 as uniformity Neighborhood
Development Plan I called on council
pemberton Thank You chairman members the
Eddington and full ready neighborhood
plan came before cabinet it's been
through its entire process culminating
in a referendum held on October the 11th
where there was a ninety-five point four
eight percent yes votes to endorse the
neighborhood plan this matter is now
before council to confirm the making of
the plan and that it be adopted with
immediate effect with the consequence
that it becomes part of the development
plan for stratford-upon-avon districts
and the second part of the
recommendation is that this council
congratulates the attic to landfill
ready neighborhood plan team on the work
that they have done in presenting the
NDP to this council and I would just
like to add my thanks both to the team
and to the policy officers for bringing
this forward so looking for agreement to
the recommendation thank you anybody
wish to raise their points on that are
we agreed with the recommendation I'll
call on council members again well as
the NEWater neighborhood planning
referendum thank you chairman in the in
brevity I'd almost be tempted to say
ditto but that would to be under under
playing the the work that's been done by
the worlds born and Wharf
neighbourhood planning group they also
have taken their neighborhood planned
through the entire process culminating
again on a referendum on the same day
where there was a ninety three point
three three percent yes vote
so again members this is before full
council the the world's born and Walton
Neighborhood Development Plan be made
and adopted with immediate effect with
the consequence that it becomes part of
the development plan for
stratford-upon-avon district and once
again that this council should
congratulate the world's born and Walton
Neighborhood Development Plan team on
their work in the report as princess to
council and again I repeat my thanks
both to the hard work of those members
of the plan group and to our officers in
bringing this NDP two to fruition thank
you yes can't go slow Thank You chair as
the ward member for Wales born East and
actually as a member of the world's born
and Walton neighborhood plan steering
committee we would just like to record
our special thanks particularly to
matthew neal john kerr furred to david
door bee and his team and the cabinet
for all their help in in helping us make
this plan and for the adoption and just
just like to record our thanks in that
respect thank you well you'll be pleased
here matthew neil sitting back at the
room
so hopefully we'll have heard your
thanks he's waved to me so i assume he
has or are we are we can we move to that
that agreed please right moving on to 19
councilwoman would introduce the
treasury management strategy midterm
review thank you chairman the mid-year
report of the council's treasury
management strategy updates the position
in the light of the prevailing economic
conditions including an update and
interest rate forecast the council's
priority is to secure is to ensure the
security of capital and liquidity and to
obtain an appropriate level of return
that is consistent with the council's
risk appetite
proved limits within the annual
investment strategy have not been
reached during the first six months and
the investment counterparty criteria
selection approved by the treasury
management strategy is meeting the
requirement of the treasury management
function the council currently has no
external borrowing or debt nor is there
an expectation that borrowing will be
undertaken during this financial year
and the recommendation is that the
treasury management strategy mid-year
review as presented be approved thank
you does anybody wish to raise any
issues on that if not are we agreed to
set the recommendation thank you I call
on councilor wall to a juicy item
adoption of personal data breach and
data innocent management policy thank
you chairman this forms part of the work
we are required to undertake to satisfy
our responsibilities under the general
data protection regulation and the data
protection and 2018 as this council is a
data controller it must have in place a
plan to detect investigate and contain
and report any breach the policy will
form part of the council information
governance framework and therefore I
would ask council please to one to note
and recommend that the personal data
breach and instant management policy be
approved and that it comes into
operation with immediate effect and
secondly that the information governance
manager be authorized in consultation
with a relevant portfolio holder to make
any subsequent changes to the personal
data breach an incident management
policy the data protection policy and
the data retention retention form and
that's certainly the head of ICT and
revenue the authorizing consultation the
relevant portfolio holder to make any
subsequent changes the ICT code of
practice and I just add one thing to
this it sounds very very complicated all
members will be getting training in this
in
I need to make sure they are covered
thank you
Thank You counsel counsel say to assure
his appointment mr. Chairman I think
we're back to where we were on water
Satya mean that we're proposing to
delegate policymaking to an officer this
time an officer in consultation with a
portfolio holder and I think that's
wrong policy decisions should be refer
back to full counsel for four counts or
to debate and endorse and amend if
necessary therefore I can't support the
proposal as its described as it's
drafted and I'm quite amazed when you
hear mr. Grafton 20 minutes ago standing
up and saying well these policy matters
are reserved for for counsel and we know
he knows he's told me enough times in
the past but that decision is embedded
in the Constitution so we're effectively
proposing in my view to make a decision
this afternoon which is counter to the
provisions of the Constitution not
because changes in policy are necessary
but it still makes them and who buries
them away and who makes a decision about
them and who effectively deals with it
and we could be totally unaware of these
changes though Custer said because comes
on you looking for any particularly
reason to come back
Thank You chairman I am quite happy for
any such policy changes to come back to
full council and through the appropriate
or failure holder do you have a seconder
for that amendment the proposal
Kansas comes the same to you second
thing mr. Thoreau was proposal we
therefore have a slight amendment to the
proposal put forward in the paper it
does come back full council all those
does anybody wish to speak mr. Grafton
data protection is quite a technical
subject if councillors really want to
bring back to themselves policy issues
about how we handle data protection so
be it but I would suggest that these
matters are quite well contained within
the recommendations where you have the
technical expertise through the data
protection officer to help Memphis Thank
You counsel permanent thank you chair
actually I'm going to disagree with
counselor say this is allowing us to
give life to the legislation brought
forward by the general data protection
regulations and the monitoring officer
is absolutely right there are a number
of complexities about this and I can
speak from my private capacity the board
of private organizations are not going
into the weeds of gdpr they are
delegating decisions around policies for
those kind of things and I think we
should follow suit this if you will
having also spent some time on GDP our
policy and implementation in a in my day
job capacity I think that members really
should be careful what they wish for
here because actually you're not
actually gonna be changing anything
anyway all you're going to do is spend a
lot of time debating something this is a
sensible way forward I absolutely agree
and wholeheartedly support the concept
that it is cabinet that should make
policy so I thought that was a Freudian
slip before not trying to take over the
world
council should be responsible for making
policy but there are sensible and
pragmatic reasons
on some occasions to let the groundwork
be done by others and this is not going
to be an area where members whatever
their views of general data protection
regulations or
privacy or anything on we're not gonna
be able to change anything so I do
wonder whether we are actually going to
put put ourselves in a position where
we'll go around in a circle for a long
time and then come to the conclusion we
should just do this thing and so I'm
going to struggle to support that I
think that we are just making it making
a rod for our own back here the council
vaudrec sorry I cut the moss I think
this is a problem of scale in proportion
I'm sure none of us have got any
difficulty with small tweaks to the
policy being made but the difficulty is
with gdpr some of this has horrendous
implications and can lead to huge
penalties to this council which the
changes in that area are I would not be
comfortable with going through without
council seeing chairman would all of
these changes in policy they're proposed
be classed as decisions that have to be
advertised to councillors and would be
subject to call in it seems to me if
that is the case and I'd be prepared to
accept this and that councillors can
look at this if necessary call it in to
overview and scrutiny if over the
scrutiny feel it should go back to
campaign council then so be it but we
don't want to do that as mr. Bratton
says on every small tweak over the
policy casts of Audrey sorry the point I
just want to make is there's one thing
saying there are certain things that
could be delegated but that decision for
delegation where I would disagree with
councillor Pendleton it should be the
responsibility is here unless this group
chooses to get it something that is so
specialist or so minor the it seems that
we're saying it should go to actually
not the proposed and second motion which
you are voted on yet but it seems
callous to Pemberton was saying it goes
to the committee who could kick it back
up here if it wanted to it should be the
other way around if it's a policy matter
it stays with us and if we choose to
delegate it so I would actually be
supporting the motion proposed by
by counsel saying because so we look at
movers we should come back on this my
word that is being taken out of my mouth
we have a map we have a motion earlier
on who which was proposed so I was it by
new council more counts the st. and
canceled cells
sorry I think we should this is
something we've heard of diversity
diversity of views I think we just have
to go straight for vote on it which is
we either adopt it as suggested or we
don't
so I'm going to ask for all those so
that doctor the recommendation as
proposed by counsel I'm slightly losing
the will flu it's mr. Buckland mr.
Buckland's magic juice let's start all
over again so I was very unfair mr.
Buckland mr. cell was amendment and
supported by counselors st. yep right
can we can we vote therefore on the
amendment so we'd like to go back to a
moment with regard to any policy
decisions which we have to make under
this particular proposal that they come
back to full council for determination
and that secondary by Cancer Center
right we're going to have a vote on
councilor walls proposal as amended all
those in favor of councilor walls
proposal
council mills have just picked up all
those against the another proposal right
the immediate first is carried can we
move on to point 21 calendar of meetings
and I'm going to invite cuz the bar
you're waving your hand are you wishing
to speak in relation to the last motion
thank you
I'm gay before we do that convite
councillor gray to introduce this item
Thank You chairman as set out in the
agenda papers there are two
recommendations from the auditing
standards committee first is for the
Canberra meetings for 2019-20 to be
agreed and a second for the provisional
date for 2020 21 to be approved Thank
You councillor Barker as the chairman of
OSC and also a parent of a child who
takes school holidays I'd just like to
point out that OSC nineteen twenty and
twenty-one occurs in the autumn half
term the first week of the summer
holidays the autumn half term again
possibly the Easter holidays beginning
thereof half term in the summer summer
holidays and onwards and the point I'm
making is not whether what the entire
thing torn up and started again but that
some thought is given to squeezing our
meetings in a different direction
because I'm not the only one as a parent
I've had people here give apologies for
various meetings on the basis that they
have grandparent duties during those
periods as well so it isn't just me that
we take some notes
of when those times are because that
particularly the think I chair is very
very difficult because it comes to
holiday times thank you thank you the
counselor Barker class the monetary
officer to respond on that all canals
how do we want to go forward those
gentlemen would it be appropriate to ask
cancer growth committee to reconsider or
shall we adopt this with a subject that
we can amend certain meeting dates at a
later stage
I suggest the latter now I suggest
therefore comes with ARCA that you
present counsel sent yes chairman what
would normally happen and I speak as
chairman of the committee I wasn't here
when the meeting took place which is why
parents are grades of that meeting but
effectively we have a situation whereby
democratic services understood all they
will effectively publish a calendar of
meetings in glorious Technicolor so I
think if we can all amend meetings we
shouldn't leave it just a sort of faith
and chance we should attend to get it
right and I will be quite happy to take
this matter back to the next committee
meeting of audience standards and look
at these dates for the OSC's because
quite frankly that has seen to be an
awfully long list but we were told about
our meetings that clash with school
vacations I'm just going to consult as
to whether we can defer this decision to
a no tomato whether we delegate it to
the Auto Service Committee
there is a timing issue which is causing
concern which I understand because the
next council meeting won't be sometime
how the council feel about delegating
authority to the ordinance and omitting
meeting to liaise with the chairman of
OSC and any other interested parties and
to delegate that decision to adopt these
at that at that time so that we don't
have to wait for the full cycle of the
next council meeting would councillors
be happy to delegate that authority to
redraft the calendar to meet the
concerns as set out by councillor barker
are we agree are we agreed on that
proposed that will delegate authority
council fragile a just actually ask that
any amended calendar is actually emailed
around to people to check that there
aren't any failures in it when it comes
out before if you see what I mean a
chairman of the audience would you be
comfortable with that right okay so the
orders house will liaise with
councillors on that one but the decision
will be made by ordinance standards at
their next hopefully at their next
meeting so that we don't have the delay
that was causing concern to mr. Webb mr.
Grafton are we agreed thank you moving
on to twitch to CCTV up where it
councillor organ-like to address this
Thank You chairman the cabinet has
resolved to proceed to upgrade the
district's CCTV and this will require
funding over and above the existing
budget and will require environment of
175,000 pounds from the ITC and revenue
budget to the CCTV budget and the
recommendation is to agree the transfer
of funds accordingly Thank You
councillor project very happy to support
this would just like to check that the
request for the evesham Road CCTV camera
will find a place within the budget
thank you Karen
offhand I can't answer that but I will
get the question - the answer to
councilor fragile a sawed-off so I'm
head of service for that CCTV service
and it is being looked at as part of the
project house organ just requesting
clarification whether that answer will
be satisfactory to cancer friendly yes
it will but I would like to know what
the conclusion of that consideration
will be as soon as possible that's
awkward and can you go back to council
photo in due course therefore without a
we are we agreed no we got cause for
checks all right just just a general
sort of no really it's CCTV cameras are
important in Stratford they do have a
role to play I think the council needs
to also note there's lots of other
spending priorities that Stratford town
requires in other ways and CCTV cameras
like a say important that they're not
the only function that we have so I just
I think we should err some caution going
forward that CCTV cameras don't solve
every problem that we have in this
district and in particular in traffic
thank you Thank You council photo trick
I'm sure that the portfolio holder will
take that point on board somebody else
like us our concern
thank you Jim just the financial
implications for the increased amount I
mean it's almost 50% of the original
budget how was the original budget
determined so that an enormous variation
has been created
okay cancer organ or mr. Grafton
okay so when you approved the budget
last March if you look at the papers
that were put forward then it was made
clear that this was a partial upgrade of
the system and at that point we hadn't
actually scoped at the whole of the
project so that there was an advert at
that time that that that budget was just
part of the solution
since then they have now scoped it out
and that is the figure Council st. from
time to time mr. chairman mr. per field
upstairs does surveys satisfaction
surveys and generally things that this
counts will compat itself on the back
about and one of the important things
from last year's customer satisfaction
survey was the importance of the CCTV
service so although there might be
cautions perhaps about finance cautions
about other priorities I think I'm a
stress to this council I'm very
supportive of this proposal but
effectively that the public liaison that
we've had over what we shouldn't
shouldn't be doing has been quite
positive about making certain that we
have a good and reliable CCTV service
Thank You council state councillor
Harris Thank You chair I just to support
council the Saints view working around
this area and the knowledge and feedback
we have is positive it does actually
impact on the fear of crime and albeit
we might think it's another camera the
impact of them is really important it
gives a lot of security to our local
community and as for councillor concerns
view on the amount our current systems
end of life it's really needs replacing
we don't want to for it to fall over
because it
costas even more and we are getting
value for money Thank You councillor
Harris our members having taken those
points on board are they're happy to
move forward with this proposal or do we
have a formal vote on it
agreed happy with that counselor
Atkinson are you happy with that counter
support check okay right moving on move
on 23 councillor Pemberton would you
address this please thank you very much
chairman so this is minute five one
eight the Harbury and Epis bridge
Neighborhood Development Plan which has
gone through its entire process and that
culminated in a referendum on the 29th
of November and so therefore came to
cabinet on the 10th of December with a
ninety four point zero five percent yes
vote endorsing the plan so the this
report is now before full council
recommending that the Harbury and Epis
bridge neighborhood development plan be
made and adopted with immediate effect
with the consequence that it becomes
part of the development plan for the
districts and it also this council
congratulates the Harbury and Epis
bridge Neighborhood Development Plan
team on their work in bringing this plan
to a conclusion and as with the the
other reports I would like to express my
own personal thanks for the hard work
for the members of the community who
brought this plan together and the hard
work of our officers in so doing so
members of council Irak asked to agree
to the recommendation Thank You
councillor Harris I just wanted to say
congratulations and thank you for all
the hard work from my local community
particularly to Pat summers and her team
they've worked hard and I understand it
was the highest turnout on the vote so I
thank you to everyone involved right any
other comments can we can we
to support that are we agreed
moving on to cell phone even they've
development plan comes to Pemberton
Thank You chairman and once again this
is the stratford-upon-avon neighborhood
development plan which itself then was
subject to its own referendum on the
same day at the 29th of November there
was a 91 point to 1% vote in favor of
the of the referendum and so that was
duly reported to cabinets on the 10th of
December so members the recommendation
to full council is that the
stratford-upon-avon Neighborhood
Development Plan be made adopted with
immediate effect with the consequence
that it becomes part of the development
plan for Stratford district members will
note the second part of the
recommendation I shall give thanks to
the officers for their hard work and I
shall sit down and watch the race first
Stratford members to thank the
neighborhood group themselves councillor
Frederic just a very endorsement under
said the fantastic support this very
very large neighborhood plan has had
from officers here and a very good
result thank you and anyone else from
Stratford wish calling that that's Robin
yes thank you
I think the neighborhood plan team in
stratford-upon-avon have done a great
job over a long long period of time and
they have really been inclusive about
everything that they have done and I
would like to congratulate them on their
work thank you council Jefferson
congratulations and I have to say it has
been an extremely long and demanding
process Thank You Elsa forchick
Stratford Town Council and the members
some of some of the members of council
all been working very hard to achieve
this yeah it's a great result it's been
a long time coming
Thank You counsel well said counselor
Ralph I think sterling work are there
any other counsel some Stratford who
wish to in which case we'll move are we
agreed to follow the recommendation
right counselor petting Pemberton can
you introduce the development of chrome
at supplementary planning document
please Thank You chairman I'm afraid
this is getting monotonous and I do
apologize so members this is a report to
you for consideration of the first nine
parts of the development requirements
supplementary planning documents known
as SPD's which provide advice and
guidance on the council's planning
policies in accordance with the core
strategy I won't read through the full
list of the policies that have been
brought forward members can see those
from from the report members these have
been brought forward in in want ranch as
work has been done on those there is
further work arising from feedback and
consultation on further parts of the SPD
and they will be brought forward the
next set of policies will be the aim is
to bring those forward for the February
council and those then hopefully can be
adopted so the recommendation for
members is that parts a b g j l m n p
and you respective parts of the
development requirements emergency
planning documents are adopted in
addition the householder guidance is to
be deleted it was it was felt on review
that this didn't actually give policy
guidance but was more a sort of usually
guide for householders and that the
change there is that that then becomes a
document on the website and becomes a
much more user-friendly and more easy to
follow guidance for householders so
therefore that the second part the
recommendation is the deletion of the
householder guidance from the SPD and
that is published on our websites as i
use a guide to householder development
happy to take any questions or move to
the recommendation thank you
Thank You German chairman I've got
concerns about two important areas R and
s both of which have been deferred
firstly which is air quality and this
council has been asked by d'être to
revoke the Stratford Town Air Quality
Management Area and the ACMA many of us
are not convinced that we solve this
problem yet chairman so I would
appreciate confirmation that this
council will not go ahead and revoke the
ACMA until the supplementary planning
document contained in this proposal has
been adopted by this council that
assurance would be very helpful chairman
especially if we could put it in the
minutes back commitment the second point
chairman is on housing which we mix
which i assume is can contained within
point s and again can i express my
concern that yet again gypsy and
traveler sites and the site allocations
decisions
oh sorry Rockland apologies German
apologies housing mix this council is
running into problems on housing mix mr.
Grafton's looking concerned am i oh that
fine point yes housing mix this council
appears to be running into some problems
on housing mix so could I ask one we
expect the SPD to be adopted for housing
mix which I assume Thank You chairman
first of all in relation to air quality
council Morris will recall this came up
at cabinet and there wasn't assurance
given at that point and I'm happy to
repeat that assurance for the benefit of
full council that the air quality they
won't be won't be revoked at this
unilaterally turning to to how to mix I
think this again turns on a point raised
by councillor moss around a recent
appeal decision by the Planning
Inspectorate which in essence meant that
if housing mix was not addressed that
out
staged that it could not then be
addressed as part of the reserved
matters and I think cancel most
expressing concern whether this would be
an ongoing problem
I mean liaison with with offices however
for some considerable time we have been
we've been approaching how's it mix at
the outline stage the were the worst
some application sites pre course
strategy and for the other hand housing
land supply where where that didn't
happen so I think the sort of cohort of
sites where that housing mix issue could
come forward and be affected by this
appeal are going to be relatively small
but I have I have committed through last
week's cabinet to provide an update to
Castle Moore's which I can move on with
in terms of the adoption of the Romanian
SPD's I just referred to the earlier and
so we're shooting for February thank you
any other comments raised on on that
basis can we move forward to the
recommendation as proposed
we agreed to standing yes I'm still
standing yes minute 41 statement of
community involvement members as you
will know we are required to have a
statement of community involvement which
sets how tired the counsel intended
intends to engage with communities
through the planning process
this was last drafted in 2014 and we are
here with a revision which actually has
the the impact of trying to slim down
and simplify the s CI and avoid
unnecessary planning jargon and to
ensure that there is reference within
the SC I noticed two uses of jargon or
acronyms there's
statement of community involvement that
neighborhood development plans are
actually intertwined and involved in
with referenced in the in the document
as is the section relating to the
community infrastructure levee and and a
section on permissions in principle
so members this is a tidying up exercise
and an updating exercise and where we
are asking having cabinets having
decided on approving this with a
recommendation to cancel that the
changes identified are formally adopted
particularly questions or if not to the
recommendation thank you anybody have
any questions comes pemberton on item of
26 no can we move forward the
recommendation or we agreed thank you
item 27 call on counts to the house to
reduce this and says next too much and
couldn't you deal with the 20 to 27 fast
council hours
thank you very much chairman I'm getting
quite used to following accounts with
Pemberton because I did when this became
before cabinet on the 10th of December
the local industrial and economic
secretary is the first time that
Stratford district counts have done this
and we're the only council locally to do
that
it sets forward our aims and ambitions
for the period running from 2018 to 2030
one the cabinet recognized that this was
an excellently produced report by
rosemary Williams they had no hesitation
in recommending it wholeheartedly as I
said it runs from the period of 2018 to
2001 to coincide with our core strategy
so I would ask the members of the
council to agree this local industrial
and economic strategy I don't actually
have the words in front of me that we've
got to say but I can recommend that it
has been totally endorsed it's been out
to consultation with stakeholders and it
was unanimously agreed I hope therefore
that you will have no hesitation in
agreeing this report I counsel saint
chairman sorry the needles got a little
bit stuck we've got a recommendation
here to identify changes
and that to formally adopt a statement
but we haven't got a copy of what those
changes imply now for example in the
representation that I gave I suggested
that we effectively diversify our
emphasis on business centers like the
venture house center because I thought
that rely on one in Stratford was not
good for a district to the size that
we've got now it could well be that
under aim one business growth and
startups my suggestions have been
adopted but I've got no evidence of that
again I think the idea of producing this
document is good which when I gave Dave
Webb a pat on the back he said well you
know he came from his appraisal and as
for the member that was responsible for
his appraisal at the time I took some
credit for that but however that's not
beep and all about it I mean it is it is
a good a good proposal but the thing is
I think it's quite important to
diversify on our business centers and
our venture houses and we should have
them in I've suggested ships to them
sell them and I'm glad that Dave Webb is
nodding his head as I speak because I
thought he was challenging me slightly
at the time so I had to challenge him
when I caught him photocopying in the
corridor one day I said no no I'm not
against venture house which is what he
was trying to suggest I might be I was
my proposal was to diversify these
centres so there were more of them
around the district so therefore again
surely we need to see the revised
documentation for adoption back at full
council thank you cancer Saint for your
comments I'm not sure that we can
accommodate you on that and our perhaps
look to mr. Webb to see whether or not
it is possible for us to consider that
mr. Webb chairman yes I remember the
conversation with cancer science on the
email and for my recollection it has all
been incorporated into the revised
strategy and I think the one thing that
you can't lose sight of there is an
action plan appending the strategy and I
think if canceled site recalls when
Venter has came into being there was
always a respiration from the council to
look at that as a blueprint and see what
we could do with other facilities across
the district that is got a commitment
and I believe that that strategy counts
us ain't you happy with that good in
which case my suggests unless anybody
else ever has any comments can we move
forward councillor Barnes I didn't
listen in cabinet good move forward I
think we need to progress it and know
what's going on
what can society if we're gonna you know
move into the rural areas but I can't
compliment the portfolio on the work
he's doing
Thank You councillor Barnes any other
comments in which case since there are
no other comments can I guess we move
forward are we happy to move ordered the
recommendation thank you
in which case I now move on to if he's
recovered councillor Pemberton pleased
to address 28 the local development
scheme Thank You members long time no
see
so members local development scheme as
members will know the local development
scheme is a work program that provides
information about the local plan and
development plan documents for the debt
for the council work has been ongoing on
the local development scheme however two
major pieces of work remain outstanding
they are the site allocations plan and
the [ __ ] em traveler plan development
requirements SPD and the council
produces a timetable the last time table
was produced in October and in an effort
to ensure that there is some clarity
about future work there is a further
timetable that has been updated in
relation to these two particular pieces
of work I would make I would make a
couple of comments in relation to the
site allocations plan and it was
originally intended that this would be
brought forward to members to be
considered before the end of the
municipal year there is further work
however to be done on the development
requirements SPD and in conjunction with
officers a number of elements have come
into play firstly there is the question
of perder that will come in will come
into play obviously as we have all up
elections in May of next year and the
work requirements to get the site
allocations plan out and consulted would
mean that we would run run potentially
interperter the other the other element
that has figured in the discussions here
is a recognition of the fact that given
the number of members of this authority
who are standing down at the end of this
municipal year we have a we will have a
minimum of 15 new members in this
authority from a cohort of 36 and
certainly in terms of trying to ensure
there's no Democratic deficit our minded
to accept and the cabinet is minded to
accept the premise that it would be it
would would perhaps potentially fetter
what is in essence a new councils views
of site allocations and so with that in
mind the the it is it has been decided
that we will not try to shoehorn that in
before before we get to the election and
you will see that the objective is that
the the cabinet and council will approve
pre-submission versions of both the
[ __ ] and Traveller plan and the site
allocations planned by July that
consultation will continue through
August and September and that we then
are aiming for a an approved submission
version to be submitted to the Planning
Inspectorate in December that would then
lead us to the final two phases of
examination and adoption clearly those
two phases are outside of our control in
terms of the length of time and the
start and end dates for the examination
we have we were suggested in a likely
window of January to July 2020 with
adoption somewhere between May and
October 2020 dependent upon the work
done by the Inspectorate I know that
councillor Morse has has some questions
so I think I'll probably just at that
point allow cancel the Maus Thank You
chairman can I just express my
disappointment that yet again we see the
Gypsy and traveler site and the site
allocations plans kick down the road
according to the timetable in front of
us as councillor Pemberton so it could
be nearly two years October 2020 before
we get these in place members will be
aware of the serious implications for
this council of that a two-year delay it
means that when things come forward from
developers gypsy and traveler sites in
particular but also major development
sites if we don't have a five year
supply we are very vulnerable in in the
planning process so I think members
should be alerted to the fact it would
be nearly two years before we like me to
have this adopt these two things
doctored and can I ask Jimmy it's a
nothing at all we can do to speed this
up council pemberton thank thank you
chairman to answer your last point first
no and to be and to be clear that there
has been some significant discussion
with officers about the practicalities
we have to get these things right and I
do acknowledge the issues but I fit
again I think you know coming back to
the question also of you know the the
likely change in makeup of this
Authority I think it's quite important
that there will be buying from you know
the new the new cohort for particularly
the site allocations planners as we move
forward in terms of gypsy and travelers
I think I would just give some comfort
to members that the the rate and flow of
applications for gypsy and travel sites
has all but dried up in recent months
members will be aware that the call for
sites has not produced any sites coming
forward so it is quite a difficult one
for us in terms of the question about
the risk factor
that we have around the the the absence
of the site allocations planner would
remind members that we do have a
five-year housing land supply and we are
we have we have adopted an approaching
the calculation of that that is in line
with the recent guidance probably non
from the the update to the MPP F so as
our officers and the cabinet are
confident that we are in a robust
position in terms of challenging sites
that are not not in that not in line
with the core strategy so I think that I
can give some assurance there to counsel
Morse and other members that the the
absence of the completion of this piece
of work in advance of the election in
May will not have a detrimental impact
impact in terms of speculative
developments of any significance Thank
You counsel Audrey doesn't make a point
on gypsy and traveler sites when I was
first elected and had temple grafted in
my patch it was something I was focused
on and back in 2014
councillor Roach told me that we would
have a plan adopted in 2014 so four
years later and three and a half years
under this administration we are no
where training we've gone backwards I
don't think is anything short than a net
I think we have all been completely
inept but I think the ruling
conservative group has has been a
complete failure on this thing and to
say oh it's fine and we got the perder
in 2020 I think it's a disgrace I
absolutely think we have totally and
utterly left residents down on this I
don't think there was any excuse I think
we've just been bloody useless honor I
think it would come as no surprise to
members to learn that I fundamentally
and wholeheartedly disagree with
everything that so council Vaudrey has
just said thank you
in my area next door which wasn't agreed
with the cabinet when we went through
the [ __ ] sites that one on appeal and
cancer brain spoke against it like I did
because we didn't have any size as it
happens we've negotiated with the
gypsy's put them all on one side and all
amicable
but at that particular time two years
ago that's what the inspector said as it
happened we've got it sorted I think and
entirely and but as far as I'm concerned
we haven't had any more sites put
forward since the two-year when we had
the public inquiry Chancellor Blaine
would confirm that I'm sure Thank You
councillor Barnes anybody else wish to
raise two points cancer Horace
no okay in which case I mean a number of
points have been made forward and I'm
sure the portfolio holder has taken
those on board
can we therefore move towards are we
happy to agree this to move forward or
do we have a vote on it we are we've cut
the bonds agreed over the page number
twenty-nine can invite councillor
cargill to a juice at the Henry Street
project please Thank You chairman a
joint bid was made to the Coventry
work shall let tourism grant scheme by
Stratford district council in the
Shakespeare Birthplace trust and it's
been accepted in principle if the match
funding is proposed is agreed this
funding will allow for major
improvements to Henley Street which is
the main tourist destination in
Stratford it's generally accepted that
Henley State has not kept pace with
modern visitor expectations and needs a
major upgrade for reference there were
four successful bids out of twenty two
applications to the CW lip two of which
are in Stratford the other being for the
traffic theatre workshops costume
workshops which is excellent news the
proposal by straight to their birthplace
across would both significantly improve
the area and implement additional and
upgraded hostile vehicle measures
improving security and bring it in line
with modern standards for pedestrian
safety there's also an aspiration from
this bid to kick start of the
Shakespeare related initiatives in
Stratford if adopted the proposals would
see a significant improvement in the
visitor experience and potential
increase in
I recommend it to the members castle
moss just continuing on the theme of
Kent's love Audrey this money has
commissioned the let there was a four
month period during which bids could be
made from May to August we made our bid
in the very last week of that four month
period chairman that meant it was
treated as urgent business could not be
called in or questioned over here
scrutiny we were not able to call it in
German this is wrong there was no
consultation with local people and local
councillors had no opportunity to
comment on this application it was kept
secret we knew nothing about it until we
saw that he had gone through without
challenge a chairman it's a bit like the
first garden the first we discovered
about this was when the planning
application came forward even though it
was September I believe when this
council first started discussing it
chairman ward members deserve to be
consulted on these things and I think
it's wrong the way we're handling these
at the very last minute so that members
can not be involved thank you it was
explained the cabinet that this bid came
forward very late from the birthplace
trust consequently it was one of those
it had to go in as quickly as physically
possible otherwise you miss an
opportunity and I think everyone would
agree it's great that we have got this
funding to go forward with it I don't
think it was secret there is commercial
sensitivity on these things as well
so you have to accept the fact that
number the circumstances yes it would be
better if it came forward to the to the
members I'm sure
but unfortunately this particular
circumstance it wasn't possible any
other point people were sure I'll go so
far cut populous yeah do what as they
Ward member for clots and with Henley
Street being in my ward I very much
welcome this this is a really good
development I think in the in the long
run it's good for local jobs and local
businesses not just in industry but in
Stratford as a whole I do have some
sympathy with council
lack of consultation but I also do
understand that the timeframe in to put
the application forward was tied so I
think the end result was the right
result but I think perhaps the more
consultation in the future would be
appreciated by members just to say yes
short and simple yes we would certainly
want to do that I think it's an exciting
scheme and hopefully it will kick-start
a number of other initiatives I know
this one David mentioned in the press
valve girls kitchen as well which is
quite an interesting initiative so
that's so this is a start of some good
things going forward thank you does
anybody have any other points which to
raise if not can we move forward to
agreeing this proposal are we agreed
thank you
now ladies and gentlemen times we're
pushing on we've got the cap in the
committee reports I'm going to ask
whether we could do this by exception
does anybody have any concerns about any
committee reports which they wish to
raise they've all been publicly
available rather than going through each
individual item give them the time or at
that it would have a problem with that
it will have to raise to n items with a
particular term and everybody happy ever
stood on block right can we can we
accept these reports right good thank
you
we then move on to 31 which is council
of questions starting off with counts of
forchick I do have a supplementary
question counsel for check
it was just the medium term say that the
it's like to be improved in medium term
what does that medium term actually mean
Thank You counsel Breen I so agree with
you cancer it's an important facility
for the town and it's maintained to keep
that facility running the elephant in
the room has been the Gateway project to
that quadrangle which is not certain at
the moment but even in that proposal as
it was the last time I saw it there was
a provision for keep in the car park in
there even if it's not in the way of
Windsor Street multi-story go to for
check I think your thank you on that
number two you'll have your number two
right we want number three then which is
councilor fragile II do you have a
supplemental question just briefly this
looks very promising but I hope it
actually goes somewhere I have actually
raised this issue at County because
county and district need to come
together to make sure that the data
flows swiftly to trigger the payment of
pupil premiums directly to the schools
rather than having to because many of
our schools at the moment are missing
out on pupil premium and that needs to
happen because because of budget
restrictions on school budgets well I'm
actually asking are those conversations
happening with district now my
information to this now there's
happening with County my information
from County is a lot of work was done
some time ago but actually it's gone
into a brick wall you are looking for
that thank you caps affirmative leave
for your supplementary question I
believe that David Platts the service
officer this has been having
conversations with Orange County Council
I will check on this immediately and
then I will send a personal response to
you when I find out what his actions
have been
thank you before council malt no
supplementary so thank to council malt
because of kind of freshly number five
just very briefly I have a lot of
residents including Friends of the Earth
who have actually done some measurements
themselves on air quality and that's why
it's a it's a it's very close to my
heart and I had she asked if we could
have a tube placed in rather streets
were a lot of children wait for buses so
if we could have a tube put there to
actually continue the measurements I'm
very happy with the insurances that have
already been given about continuing
measurements in the time well just
insurance that a tube in Mother Street
will be more than considered I like you
council if actually have this is a
concern at my heart and I have been
raising questions like you about it you
can see my response here and also we
discussed earlier about having certain
strategies in place before we make any
recommendations or decisions and
wholeheartedly in support of that just
to go one further and I'm I've also
asked mr. perks about the bus stops in
Stratford town I know there's we've
taken action of stopping them standing
and idling adding to the pollution also
there's been discussions about
relocating them but I think there's a
resistance from our communities on that
so if you've got any ideas or input
around that where we could progress
change to improve the town center I'm
all ears
and finally the you bus is another
interesting one we don't run buses
ourselves in this district as you know
it's not our responsibility
it's at councils but I do think there's
potential for us to have more electric
buses and some of these won't fit in our
criteria new buses win by a different
source but I am exploring ideas around
maybe we could have that as an
electronic purse instead of the petrol
diesel I'm not saying this is the answer
I'm not saying but I think without
exploring so anything you want to bring
forward I'm all ears
okay can we move on then to cancer stuck
at number six cuz the Morse Thank You
capsule Morse counselor seven counts to
right do you have a supplementary
question it's very sensible and they're
very struggling robust but it doesn't
quite answer the question with I was
asking since the summer the advice given
about lighting low-level lighting has
been reduced and reconsidered and I
could give you a long list of why that
is but I won't because it will take for
ages but the other reason I was a bit
disappointed in the response was there's
been no discussion with our
environmental health department because
there is a very slight maybe actionable
under the clean neighborhoods an
environmental act 2006 and also the
environment protection act 1990 all I'm
saying is look a little bit more closely
at the Vice we were given and make
absolutely sure but it's in line with
current thinking certainly take your
points on board the one thing I would
say is that often there is a trade-off
between there is different elements and
that often is an issue but certainly
I'll take up the points
because which on my son counts the Rowlf
do you have a supplemental question
counselor Barnes 2015 them hospital came
to me and asked me about these 106
agreements pasta to that the district
council was doing some work but the
government don't take into consideration
houses with the hospital funding and
there were a year later so that's why
the proposal was put forward I worked
closely with the hospital and their
public inquiry spoke for them sometimes
they spoke for me and as far as we were
concerned
the lady left Warwick and went to shop
here 18 months ago and I thought the
figure then was 1.4 million but
unfortunately it does appear that the
figure is I can't get hold of her now
but we were working closely together and
the figure we thought was one point four
million 18 months ago I've thought it
would have gone up but it appears to
have gone down
all I can say is that the six hundred
and fifty five thousand six hundred and
sixty pounds is a figure of being given
I will check heed what I'm pretty sure
this is accurate number ten Kansas eight
do you have sup good question yes mr.
chair it seems from this answer there's
there's been an attempt to sidestep the
question by suggesting that we had a
temporary arrangement with which Aven
District Council the email we received
didn't suggest it was a temporary
arrangement it suggested that it was a
permanent arrangement and when I wrote
in and sort of said can someone I asked
this question by email to somebody or
other some weeks ago
and I've never had a response now it
seems to me that even a temporary
arrangement with a neighboring Council
would have warranted a notice of
decision so that all members could get
hold of it and we could all understand
the implications now then can someone
confirm that the effectively we breached
our own decision-making principles in
dealing with it in the way that this
answer implies sank there were a number
of changes over the four years from 2014
when the Walker County Council changed
their administration and we put into
place a temporary arrangement with which
Ivan which came to the cabinet on the
10th of December which was the first
time it was appropriate to bring it to
the cabinet for decision if you'd have
been there you could have asked the
question moving forward can't serve
Audrey do you have a supplementary
question I do miss the chair so thank
you for the answer I wanted to ask the
following is the action pam plan public
in which case can you circulate it to us
all
does it specifically address the point I
raised which is a point now specifically
how to residents asked me about because
someone was saying they're spending
seven hundred eighty pounds they didn't
have to now pay for the bus and they
don't really want to so they're using
the car and that's all point to this
what is your view don't bounce me around
with some bloody committee what's your
view and what's the timing when do we
actually get a resolution or is there
something else that gets kicked down the
road thank you to the regards the
resolution yes a work in progress okay
um all right I note that the question on
the transport strategy is to reduce hike
our dependency particularly for travel
to work and school
if the suggestions forward through
logically then perhaps the member
suggestion we also support people going
to work well I'm sure you don't but but
of course I'm not sure this case but it
does beg the question where to start and
to a stock the subsidies and sort of
like I share however the frustration of
members about the apparent lack of
progress of transport latest games in
the district I do sit on the transport
group of County I'll come to that in a
second I can report that the last
transport group meeting in November is
only a few weeks ago this exact sublet
was raised and specifically I've our
study in the New Year an action plan be
produced detailing these works around
the district so I'm hopefully going to
try and get some more more actions on
those particular points the next group
meetings in March April I hope by the
time we'll have this I will circulated
if it's for public scrutiny and I have
no problems at all about doing that and
so the next group meetings in March
April I also note we have a new member
representing Stratford so perhaps he can
also add his wait it to the to the
County Council as well because obviously
the part of this is the County Council
No don't get excited
that's somewhere else there's another
chamber Thank You counsel Audrey
question number 12 you've had a response
from councilor Pemberton do you have a
something much a question yes on the
17th of August 2016 at planning meeting
it was coun counselor fragile e he
sought clarification of the committee
and specifically he asked and was
assured on more than one occasion that
what we were voting for the committee
was the principle of development and
points have access to the site this is
about the bishop and development of five
hundred odd homes what my client what my
residence the Bragg's group are now
being told is all no that wasn't the
case actually what was what was agreed
at that meeting was something far more
substantive and we can't make sort of
any material ranges so all the
greeneries there because apparently was
a picture there was some sketch attached
that planning application so my
residents have asked me to make it clear
that they believe they were at the in
factory in particular was misled at that
meeting given how serious that is I note
councilor Pemberton's response but
actually I suppose what I was hoping was
as port
rather than a member it will be you who
would take up so the code of conduct
violations or I thought this support
would be something that the origin can
sandins committee should be
investigating to look back at what was
actually said to residents and to
councilor Friday at their time and
determine whether actually that was a
something that was misleading to them
and then what is the fallout what
lessons do we learn on that basis Thank
You chairman Thank You councillor
Vaudrey how many broad terms my answer
stands and I think it is ordinarily the
case that if there are concerns about
the management of or what is said at a
planning committee the relevant parties
involved whether that be a ward member
or it might be an applicant are the
people that bring forward a complaint if
you will I'm not aware that am fragile
ii has brought any complaint forward
what you now seem to be saying is that
following on from further discussions
there's an issue I'm not I'm not sure
there's anything that I'm being asked to
sort of you know initiate an
investigation for and I'm not actually
sure from the monitoring officer whether
I'm in a position to quote instigate a
complaint so before I go any further
quite right so councillor Pemberton this
is still alive matter there are routes
through which people can make complaints
challenges but it isn't through this
chamber okay I think that probably tells
me where I can go with this I think all
that all that I can say is that I mean
there is a life plan application and it
does allow for people to you know for
those interested parties to to make
submissions
I think that's buddies that is the route
through I think if there are any
specific areas whether this felt
there's been some point where the
process has not been followed I think I
just got to go back and say somebody has
to make a formal a formal a formal
request that that be investigated and we
take that as a separate matter I'm just
struggling to see where I can go with
this is there's a life plan application
I am also conscious that there will be
people in this room who are on the
planning on the planning committee who
may be sort of looking at this so I'm
really not sure I can take this further
forward and unless Council of Audrey can
can arrange offline for the you know
that those interested to to make some
specific approaches through through the
monitoring officer thank you thank you
Pemberton last point is counts the
Saints point you've had a response from
Council house
yes Chairman's just briefly I think
these signs look rather forlorn and I
appreciate the fact that we're now going
to get some action taken in consultation
with the County Council thank you can I
suggest or ask that effectively the
district's interest do get strongly
promoted to the County Council and we
can make certain that they are sort of
fully utilized it comes to house I can
give you those assurances council say
thank you very much for the question it
just so happens that Lindsey Armstrong
from the Guildhall has already been
talking to me about the problem that
they are experienced the signs that
point to the Guildhall
which is an important tourist attraction
so yes we're on the case and we will
make the strongest recommendation as
possible to Washoe County Council to get
this rush through when we can right in
which case you move on to questions the
leader
there's gentleman we are now at five
minutes past five we have a we have
another 25 minutes to go
clearly if we take up the full 30
minutes we will be over our time
allocation I'll encourage us to if we
can move swiftly through the next stage
see if we can beat the clockwise
there may be no course questions the
leader other can ask are there any
questions of the me leader so from -
calcified check - questions they're both
connected so us both well just like to
thank however some family is pushed on
to universal credit won't have a Merry
Christmas in fact they'd be quite a
miserable Christmas what actions will
leader make in the next year to allow
Stratford district council to take
further measures to relieve pain for
some of the families that are struggling
not just this Christmas but also into
next year and the second question is
food banks across the country have never
been so busy Strafford food bank is no
exception
the number of residents that end up
using food banks is a direct consequence
of the policies of austerity and benefit
cuts for working families by this
government would council Jefferson look
at ways of Stratford district council
can find urgent ways to reduce the need
for food banks in the district taking
both those questions together
councillor phytic I'm not actually sure
what we can do but we will look at both
those areas caocao wardrip Vaudrey two
questions
first one to the leader when you still
portfolio holder there was a debate
about the police the police issue came
up and I challenge that you were saying
you were going to be a critical friend
of the police and you assured me that
you would actually kind of really begin
to make a difference with the police and
crime Commissioner the Chief Constable
can you just spell out as portfolio
holder and now as leader what what
difference you've made with the police
particularly in light of them splitting
with West Mercia and all the fallout and
it appears they had no knowledge of that
and also I'm slightly alarmed to find
out that actually the precepts they're
being considered or
going up when I seem to remember the
police and crime Commissioner when he
was a counselor here was probably the
most vocal about keeping as I see
hanging smiles there about keeping
making sure that taxes were flat it
seems a sigh irony Thank You councillor
Vaudrey there have been a number of
meetings specifically on what is
happening with the dissolution of the
relationship between West Mercia and
Warwickshire at the moment the way
forward is not clear we had a meeting
this morning where we were briefed once
again on the issue they are looking at a
number of options it is quite obvious
that this cam is a surprise to both the
Chief Constable
and the police and crime Commissioner
there are now a number of options being
looked at or a combination of them one
is Warwickshire standalone the other one
the other another is to continue parts
of the relationship with mass Mercia and
now there is to look at possible
relationships with other forces there
has been some quite considerable
questioning of both the police and crime
Commissioner and the Chief Constable on
this and I should say that when one's in
the meeting of the police in crime panel
or other meetings it is not just me that
he's asking questions I have to say from
my point of view having been involved in
a number of merges I think the issues in
disentangling the relationship between
West Mercia and Warwickshire are going
to be a little more significant than
might have been anticipated indeed that
was recognised today by the Chief
Constable
where it would appear as though the
dissolution of the relationship could
easily take much longer than just the
date next year
that's been given in terms of the
precept the points were made this
morning that perhaps a considerable
number of residents might struggle with
24 pounds the point was also made that
in reality if border more of the money
for the police and crime Commissioner
and the police is provided locally then
it is actually the priorities of local
residents that will become more
important and that they police will have
to be seen to be delivering for local
people and I think that the minute of
the pressure is increasing on the police
to actually deliver for local people
that is not just me making the points I
have to say that it is my colleagues on
the police and crime panel as well I
mean a second question
it's a different topic for you later
could you just reassure me and my
residents who are in favor of it that
the southwest relief Road is still a
clear policy preference for Stratford
district council and could you update us
on what the funding is of that road I
can actually issue you on the first
point on the second point with funding
is still under discussion so I can't
clarify anything on that Thank You
councillor Richard thank you and there's
three elements to my question please
leader and they said this has been
brought about from the question that was
raised by councilor most question number
four in our papers and he's referring to
using our own council own land to
provide affordable housing and the
response we've had is if that scenario
were to partner it's come to pass and it
would likely provide a revenue stream to
my way of thinking that scenario has
been presented to us in two different
ways one through a local housing company
and the facility for us to be able to
actually build on our own land and sea
housing for the residents of Stratford
at the cabinet meeting in November the
direction of travel for the local
housing company seems to take a wild
change of direction and we are now from
what I can understand from reading that
we are now reviewing the process in
which we're looking at providing these
houses having that had been agreed in
April unanimously by this council the
second part would be the canal quarter
regeneration this time last year
possibly early into this year we were
approached by a developer who were
seeking to include our land in a deal to
regenerate the entirety of the canal
court or indeed that is part of our core
strategy is to pro to regenerate that
area of Stratford we discussed at that
time different ways in which one could
generate a revenue stream one was a
windfall of cash
there was another element and then also
a share in profits have we got any
further down the line with that deal is
it still on the table or is it just
being ignored or kick the can kick down
the road and secondly as part of that
section of my question we obviously have
a five-year housing land supply the
canal quarter regeneration is part of
that five-year housing line supply if we
don't provide the housing on that site
at what point does our five-year hasn't
land supply come in to challenge given
that we've heard from our portfolio
holder that our reserve sites have been
not going to be reviewed until July next
year
thank you just picking up the first
point about the council and if that is
in the books at several million pounds
then the reality is if we use that land
to build houses arm its 4.2 million
pounds that's the opportunity cost and
we could obviously sell it for that and
I'm sure this section one five one
officer might have words with us if we
decided to build on it for free the
second point the regeneration of the
area
there is no clarity on the dealers yet
on the table but discussions are still
ongoing with the developer
they have been slightly delayed but
nevertheless there is still strong
interest in actually developing the
canal quarter and discussions will
continue early next year on the third
point the five-year housing land
supplied obviously I cannot do the
calculations here now but the
calculations will be done and I will let
you know but what I would stress is that
they may well be confidential
if I may just very quickly can you make
it known if it's necessary on blook
papers to all the counselors here
because I do have a concern that our
five-year house in that supply could get
challenged and with we don't have our
reserve sites lined out and ready to go
we have a serious problem I will take
advice on that
but if possible the answer's yes but I
will take advice I've seen that right
there are no other questions for the
leader will move on to 33 notice of
motion this is just an update I'm
assuming there were no nobody we should
raise any issues on the 33 indicates
move on to 34 I call on councils fragile
e and naught to propose ii the following
motion a motion no which will then be
did debated haven't ones been first and
seconded
Thank You chair I would like to propose
the motion at the bottom of the page
under item 34 the council has accepted
the offer of a gift of the peony
pavilion thank you
right stab being proposed to the
seconded I propose this is referred to
cabinet so council Adams have got a no
in which case referred to cabinet who
will consider it for a report without
debate on 235 there are no items I've
advised or and items and therefore 36
it's not on the agenda but it is now the
last meeting of this year the last
meeting mr. Webb's tenure I wish you all
very happy Christmas I'm proud to doing
that
councillor Adams has very kindly made
and donated mince pies and apple pies
which I know she wouldn't want me to may
raise her name in public but I forgot
that at the appropriate moment so Thank
You councillor Adams please feel free
and there is that there's some red wine
for those who wish to feel a little bit
Julia as well
and I apologize as well for my slight
hiccup during castle thermal sponsored
Iran can't mr. Buckland's magic potion
is actually now working fine so I
declare this meeting